da muss noch ein wesentlicher einzeln
beraten werden nämlich der für arbeit
und soziales es ja mit abstand der
größte einzelplan im bundeshaushalt mit
161 milliarden euro das sind
32,5 prozent des gesamten haushaltes von
495 milliarden euro und zusammen mit
diesem einzelplan wird auch beschlossen
werden mutmaßlich der gesetzliche
mindestlohn der soll auf zwölf euro
erhöht werden
ab ersten oktober soll das dann der fall
sein das ist ja ein projekt mit dem die
spd in den wahlkampf gegangen ist und
dass die ampel koalitionäre sich in den
koalitionsvertrag geschrieben hatten
also der gesetzliche mindestlohn der
zurzeit noch bei 9 eur 82 liegt wie
gesagt der soll angehoben werden und es
geht auch um die ausweitung der minijobs
grenze übrigens in diesem gesetzentwurf
von derzeit 450 euro auf 520 euro also
das alles steckt jetzt in dieser debatte
drin erste rednerin wird jetzt sein
silke launert für die unionsfraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren
frau und herr müller möchten gerne für
sich und ihre beiden kinder ein haus
bauen
luxusgut natürlich und kleines
gemütliches für die familie ein zuhause
stückchen garten und wie die meisten
häuslebauer müssen sie dafür kredit
aufnehmen und gehen bis ans limit ja und
dann leider während der bauphase steigen
die kreise baumaterial
die kosten gehen nach ihren was tun frau
und herr müller
richtig sie merken wenn ich den traum
von unserem eigenheim weiterhin haben
wir nun realisieren will muss ich an
anderer stelle mich einschränken das
kann konkret bedeuten ich muss auf dem
sommerurlaub mit der familie nach
italien verzichten ich kann als nicht
mehr shoppen gehen restaurantbesuch
gefallen aus viele kaufen nur noch im
supermarkt reduziert lebensmittel im
angebot das ist die realität
tja und der ein oder andere wird
vielleicht sogar auch mal bei den
geschenken sparen einschränkungen die
sind schmerzlich aber
nötig herr ian foreman anerkennen in
einfachen zusammenhang wenn ich mehr
schulden aufnehmen muss wenn ich mehr
geld in die hand nehmen muss als
zunächst geplant dann muss ich an
anderer stelle sparen eine einfache
rechnung müsste man meinen
[Musik]
leider seien aber nicht alle diesen
simplen zusammenhang zu verstehen zu
erkennen oder erkennen zu wollen
und das trifft auf die neue
bundesregierung zu insgesamt 300
milliarden
139 schmidt den im haushalt 100 extra
durch die bundeswehr sondervermögen 60
milliarden vorher an der schuldengrenze
vor beigemischten 300 milliarden
schulden schulden schulden schulden das
ist das was bleibt von diesem ersten
jahr der bundesregierung
und ganz ehrlich diese versuche irgendwo
einzusparen alles zu durchsuchen können
auch was verzichten weil die hörner
große herausforderung dieses angst hafte
bemühen und ich leider überhaupt nichts
feststellen
über die sp will ich gar nicht reden als
sie das ist aber eine 180 grad wende ich
kann mich an die vielen regen von
rhetorisch brillant hier erinnern die
denn jetzt gar nichts mehr damit zu tun
haben was jetzt hier der fall ist aber
ob sie spd mit respekt gegenüber den
steuerzahlern mit respekt gegenüber der
künftigen generation hat es nichts zu
tun und es ist schade dass man sie daran
die verantwortung erinnern muss
gegenüber 83 millionen menschen
und denn man hat den eindruck die fis in
der koalition werden gekittet indem man
sagt dessen wunsch dursten von sturm
lothar könig zusammen jeder kriegt sein
wunsch erfüllt das ist konflikt
beigelegt problem gelöst sache vom tisch
das ist die kompromisslösung alle ampeln
auf kosten der steuerzahler
aber ganz ehrlich die menschen merken
dass die marken dass das nicht so gut
gehen kann was ist die folge
vertrauen in die regierung vertrauen in
den staat und die politik in den tag
dabei ist dieses vertrauen so wichtig
für eine gesellschaft für den
zusammenhalt als recht in einer
demokratie
vor den ganzen großen herausforderung
der inflation wiederwahl lösung aller
ampel jeder kriegt was auch nur
vorübergehend auch nur einmalig auch
rentner nicht betroffen will ich gar
nicht mehr eingehen es tut macht mein
kollege dann aber letztlich ist es eine
koalition der zumindest in den medien
immer wieder auftauchenden schönen
menschen schöne worte schöne gesten
schöne show aber diese fundamentale
situation dieser herausforderung die wir
hier haben auch etwas anderes
schade dass sie dieses nicht ernst
nehmen mehr liebe zum haushalt immer das
risiko dass zu viele zahlen erwähnt
werden um zu viele einzelposition
deshalb möchte ich mich auf wenige
begrenzen die
ist 450 millionen
das ist die summe die die ampel
investiert für einen übergang zum
bürgergeld knapp 450 millionen allein in
diesem jahr das heißt in den folgejahren
rede von zig milliarden die benutzt
werden ob abzukehren von dem prinzip des
förderns und forderns
ein weg der ganz klar ist denn die ampel
hier beschreibt weckfunktion satz
leistung muss sich lohnen mitwirkung
muss sich lohnen hin zum bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen
das ist schade denn das prinzip des
förderns von hat uns in den vergangen
hat uns in der vergangenheit sehr
geholfen es hat uns geholfen die
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit zu überwinden
und gerade in der jetzigen situation sie
kriegen doch überall kleine fachkräfte
oder fachkräfte normale arbeitskräfte
mehr der bäcker mussten tagen schließen
weil er kein verkaufspersonal hut
restaurants cafés müssen schließen weil
sie keine bedeutung mehr haben wir haben
überall fachkräftebedarf und wir
signalisieren
macht nichts kann aktionen am besten
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen das ist
doch in der jetzigen zeit das völlig
falsche signal
meine zeit kostet ja noch natürlich 25
milliarden die zweite 2 gesagt die
natürlich auch überhaupt nicht
ausreichend ist für die flüchtlinge da
wusste ich genau erlitten aber unbedingt
seine 139 milliarden und damit man nicht
sagen kann er ist der spitzenreiter die
leute nach ist es trotzdem 300
milliarden und zum schluss ein erkennen
eigentlich an der literatur schon nicht
mehr da ist der weiß schon warum
nehmen sie sich ein beispiel an frau und
herr müller sie wissen man muss
prioritäten setzen wenn die kosten
steigen die wissen geld steuergeld nicht
mit der gießkanne aus zu verteilen sie
übernehmen verantwortung für die nächste
generation und über nämlich schulden die
ihre kinder abzahlen müssen am ende gilt
doch das was den kleinen gilt muss auch
im großen gelten
die werke dort war das hier mit dem
auftakt zu den beratungen der einzelplan
arbeit und soziales und glücklicherweise
sprechen die
berichterstatterin und berichterstatter
aus dem haushaltsausschuss zu dem
einzelplan zu beginn der debatte und
auch natürlich die zuständigen minister
jetzt der bundesarbeitsminister hubertus
heil
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren sicherheit und frieden
das sind die zentralen prioritäten der
bundesregierung in diesen schwierigen
zeiten das gilt und das ist in dieser
woche der rede des bundeskanzlers
deutlich geworden nach außen das muss
aber auch im innen gehen das gilt auch
für die sozialen aufgaben und
herausforderungen vor denen unser land
steht und frau kollegin viele menschen
machen sich im moment sehr sehr große
sorgen das ist vollkommen richtig wenn
die preise steigen die energiepreise
steigen nicht nur an der zapfsäule
sondern auch vor der nächsten
heiztechnik viele menschen machen sich
sorgen denn lebensmittelpreise steigen
wenn ein stück butter mittlerweile fast
ein euro kostet und menschen mit ihrem
einkommen verlängert und mit meinem die
finden das ärgerlich aber die können das
tragen diese bundesregierung sorgt für
konkrete entlastungen für menschen mit
normalem und mit geringem einkommen und
das ist unsere priorität
weil es gilt in diesen schwierigen
zeiten unsere gesellschaft
zusammenzuhalten und ich will ihnen sehr
sehr konkret sagen was wir tun es ist
der dreiklang aus drei dingen jetzt
notwendig sind um in diesen schwierigen
zeiten dieser gesellschaft
zusammenzuhalten erstens es geht um
einen robusten arbeitsmarkt und
anständige löhne geben und mit blick auf
die zahlen dieser woche können wir sagen
bei aller schwierigkeit der
preisentwicklung wir können sehr sehr
froh sein dass wir nach zwei jahren
corona krise und in dieser kriegs krise
die auch unsere wirtschaft belastet
einen sehr robusten arbeitsmarkt in
deutschland haben wir haben am dienstag
die zahlen der bundesagentur für arbeit
in nürnberg gehört wir sind inzwischen
bei der arbeitslosenquote wieder vor der
korona krise wir sind bei 4,9 prozent
und das ist kein deutsches wunder das
ist das ergebnis harter arbeit und der
einsatz von kurzarbeit maßgeblich dazu
beigetragen ausbaut ist ein wichtiger
tag
wenn wir aber darüber reden wie wir in
dieser zeit die gesellschaft
zusammenzuhalten dann hat das auch mit
anständigen löhnen zu tun meine damen
und herren und deshalb ist es gut und
richtig dass du mit diesem haushalt
heute endlich in zweiter und dritter
lesung die erhöhung des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns auf 12 euro beschließen
herzlichen dank an die kollegen der
arthrose zu waschen
die finnmark konkret sagen was das
bedeutet
diese erhöhung auf 12 euro hat dem
ersten oktober vor wird der mindestlohn
übrigens auf 10 eur 45 zum ersten juli
angehoben das ist für viele menschen für
sechs millionen menschen in deutschland
vor allen dingen ist für viele frauen
und für viele beschäftigte in
ostdeutschland
möglicherweise der größte lohn sprung in
ihrem leben von 22 prozent wer bisher
vollzeit auf basis des mindestlohns
brutto 1
1700 euro im monat verdient der kriegt
zukünftig 2100 euro das ist immer auch
noch nicht die welt aber es spürbar im
portemonnaie eine verbesserung die in
dieser zeit zu menschen wirksam wird auf
messen was anderes als ihr geredet
verlor
ich war im februar in bornstedt in
sachsen anhalt in einer bäckerei und hat
mit einer bäckereiverkäuferin darüber
gesprochen die davon profitieren würden
gesagt ja das ist etwas was in diesen
zeiten mir das leben ein stück leichter
dass ich über die runden kommen aber es
ist vor allen dingen ist frage des
respekts vor meiner arbeit vor dem was
ich und meine kollegin hier leisten ich
war gestern in der reinhardtstraße
gegenüber übrigens lukas kohler der
parteizentrale der fdp da gibt es im
friseursalon ich habe mit der
friseurmeisterin gesprochen frau schwer
die in diesen friseursalon mit einer
kollegin einer auszubildenden arbeitet
ich habe sie gefragt mensch ich höre
jetzt immer von arbeitgeberverbänden das
ist so ein druck auf die wirtschaft dass
wir jetzt auf 12 euro gehen sie sagt ja
das ist eine aufgabe für mich aber ich
will dass meine beschäftigten anständig
bezahlt werden nicht mit fairen
wettbewerb ich will nicht dass menschen
die mit harter arbeit mit dem
friseurhandwerk was ein ordentlicher
ausbildungsberuf ist abgespeist werden
mit löhnen über die mit denen sie nicht
über die runden kommen die frau ist für
den winter
wir wissen aber auch als bundesregierung
meine damen und herren dass der
mindestlohn der jetzt auf 12 euro steigt
immer nur eine absolute lohnuntergrenze
ist das ziel der bundesregierung ist
nicht dass alle zwölf euro bekommen aber
das dass die absolute untergrenze ist
wir wollen auch wieder mehr tariflöhnen
in deutschland deshalb werden wir dafür
sorgen dass
hat werden wir dafür sorgen dass
aufträge des bundes zukünftig nur an
unternehmen gehen die nach tarif
bezahlen war der damen und herren das
ist klar verankert im koalitionspoker
wir werden das durchsetzen von
dienstwägen was zur cdu/csu sagen ich
finde ist es hier herrlich vorzuwerfen
dass sie eigentlich mal gegen den
mindestlohn gegen die einführung 2015
waren und dass meine partei die spd das
damals mit andrea nahles gegen sie
durchsetzen das ist vollkommen in
ordnung das ist geschichte
ich habe da ganz 1 erlebt man da haben
sie sich doch mal treu im
bundestagswahlkampf fahren sie gegen den
mindestlohn 55 euro hier waren dafür
und olaf scholz als bundeskanzler hat
klar gesagt wenn wir die spd wählen wenn
der bundeskanzler wird wird der
mindestlohn auf 12 euro steigen die
menschen in deutschland wissen ohne ein
bundeskanzler olaf scholz wäre der
mindestlohn jetzt nicht bei 12 euro im
oktober des jahres nicht mit ihnen
unterzogen
weil wir das ist vielleicht ein
unterschied verlängert weil sie über
vertrauen gesprochen haben das was wir
vor der wahl sagen auch machen und jetzt
will ich nur angucken was sie vor der
nrw wahl gemacht haben vor der nordrhein
westfälischen landtagswahl hat der wüste
und herr laumann und der märz und einer
kölner erklärung gesagt sie sagen jetzt
auf 12 euro und dann ist diskutiert
wurde der cdu-obmann zustimmt und hat
man gesagt man würde zustimmen dann
haben sie moderne fraktions hinzu gehabt
und das ergebnis ist dass es sich heute
heldenhaft enthalten ich kann ihnen
sagen dass es peinlich an dieser stelle
wenn es um menschen geht wie ein kleines
einkommen haben die hart arbeiten dann
ist enthaltung keine haltung dass es
peinlich was die cdu hier wieso
das ist wirklich kein licht man kann
seine meinung vertreten aber sich
wegzuducken in einer zeit in der
menschen darauf angewiesen sind über die
runden zu kommen ist das keine haltung
ist es geht um eine anständige bezahlung
deutsche das geht und stabilen
arbeitsmarkt es geht aber um was
zweitens
und beide damen und herren es geht auch
um einen starken sozialstaat der sich
tatsächlich nicht nur darum bemüht
sozialen ausgleich zu organisieren
sondern auch lebensleistung zu umrühren
wir werden heute nachmittag
mit dem renten paket 1 gott sei dank
dafür sorgen dass es die größte renten
an die unser 30 jahren gibt mit 6,1
prozent in ostdeutschland und 5,3
prozent im westen das ist sage ich ihnen
krisenzeiten wichtig geschrieben haben
ich will ihnen mal sagen dass sie nicht
wissen wie das rentensystem funktioniert
das blatt kann ich ihnen auch nicht aber
sie könnten sich das
leben deutlich sagen an dieser stelle
das haben die menschen sich auch
verdient weil die renten der
lohnentwicklung dem arbeitsmarkt ist im
vergangenen jahr folgen der arbeitsmarkt
gott sei dank stabil geblieben ist wir
müssen und werden den sozialstaat aber
auch weiterentwickeln meine damen und
herren mit der einführung des
bürgergeldes beispielsweise zum ersten
ersten renten paket das dafür sorgt dass
die renten auch langfristig für alle
generationen stabil sind dass die
menschen sich auf die rente verlassen
können und zwar alle generationen
deshalb werden wir das rentenniveau
stabilisieren der bundeskanzler meine
damen und herren hat in seiner rede in
dieser woche angesichts der aktuellen
lage zu einer konzertierten aktion
eingeladen
gewerkschaften arbeitgeber den start und
alle werden ihren beitrag leisten müssen
um mit dieser schwierigen zeit des
preisdrucks mitzuhelfen dass diese
gesellschaft sozialer zusammenhalt
ergebnis um löhne da geht es um
entlastung und es geht auch darum dass
der sozialstaat funktioniert dafür steht
diese bundesregierung das ist unsere
haltung und ich bin den
koalitionsfraktionen dankbar nicht nur
dass er mit diesem haushalt dazu sorgen
dass der sozialstaat gut funktionieren
kann und gut ausgestattet ist sondern
dass wir bei aller notwendigkeit
zu menschen auch in diesen zeiten nicht
aus dem blick zu verlieren es geht nicht
nur um sozialen ausgleich uns als
koalition geht es auch um sozialen
fortschritt für deutschland herzlichen
dank
bundesarbeits und sozialminister
hubertus heil
heute hat er einiges hier aus seinem
hause nicht nur den einzelplan den das
parlament für sein ressort beschließt
den größten des haushaltes sondern auch
der mindestlohn der auf zwölf euro
steigen soll dann ab oktober das wird
heute hier direkt nach der debatte
übrigens auch abgestimmt
es ist noch gar nicht so lange her da
standen wir hier und debattierten in der
ersten lesung über den bundeshaushalt in
diesem fall über den etat für arbeit und
soziales und jedem war klar das was die
bundesregierung dafür vorgesehen hatte
es reicht hinten und vorne nicht aus die
inflation lag bereits bei über 7% putin
hatte die ukraine überfallen und
deutschland stand am beginn einer
schweren rezession
statt die sozialausgaben
zusammenzustreichen hätte man also
vorsorgen müssen doch wie sie wissen war
das gegenteil der fall die regierung
rechnete sich die welt schön mit weniger
arbeitslosen mit weniger kurzarbeit und
vor den kosten für die versorgung der
ukrainischen flüchtlinge war auch noch
nicht die rede dafür aber von einem
ergänzungs haushalt der alters
beinhalten sollte was irgendwie mit
ukraine zu tun hat und der nun vorliegt
nachdem man die sozialausgaben also
vorher um knapp fünf milliarden gekürzt
hatte werden nun 2,5 milliarden wieder
eingestellt nur wofür das weiß keiner
denn das steht da nicht drin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist keine
seriöse haushaltspolitik
ja es ist richtig
wir leben in schwierigen zeiten richtig
ist aber auch das wenigste davon habe
putin oder bewohner zu tun wir haben in
deutschland seit vielen jahren einen
ungebremsten und ungeheuerlichen
wohlstandsverlust das ist die folge
einer desaströsen politik zum schaden
unserer wirtschaft und zu lasten unserer
bürger das ist der grund weshalb immer
mehr unsere rentner die ihr leben lang
gearbeitet haben von grundsicherung
leben das ist der grund weshalb viele
menschen ihre stromrechnung nicht mehr
zahlen können und das ist der grund
weshalb den arbeitnehmern auch den
normalverdienern am monatsende so wenig
übrig bleibt all diese menschen fragen
sich zu recht was macht die regierung
eigentlich mit dem ganzen geld und da
sind wir wieder beim thema haushalt ich
muss sagen ich war doch erstaunt als die
kollegin raffelhüschen in der letzten
debatte ausführte ich zitiere
glücklicherweise verfügen wir über die
höchste steuerquote am
bruttoinlandsprodukt in unserer
geschichte mehr geld wurde die menschen
hierzulande noch nie über steuern und
beiträge entzogen das liebe fdp wäre
letztes jahr zur selben zeit kein grund
zur freude gewesen so schnell kann man
seine meinung ändern
denn das abgreifen der deutschen
wirtschaft durch die energie und
sonstwas wende das kostet nicht nur
arbeitsplätze wohlstand und
infrastruktur auch eine menge geld das
wir nicht haben und geld an dass wir nur
herankommen wenn wir schulden plötzlich
als sondervermögen bezeichnen warum
erzähle ich das weil klar ist was ich an
einer stelle verschwende muss ich an
anderer stelle einsparen und das tut die
regierung nämlich bei den ausgaben für
arbeit und soziales und nein es ist für
die bürger kein trost hier und dort
almosen aus sogenannten entlastungs
paketen zu erhalten wir reden hier über
einmalzahlungen für empfänger von
grundsicherung die bei weitem nicht
ausreichen um die folgen der inflation
abzumildern und die rentner bekommen
noch nicht einmal das das heißt sie
fahren auf sicht und auch das noch in
die falsche richtung eine solche politik
entmündigt die menschen unsere bürger
brauchen keinen neuen euro tickets für
drei monate sondern ausreichende rente
und einkommen um ihr leben selbst zu
gestalten
lassen sie mich als rentenpolitische
sprecherin unserer fraktion nun auf die
punkte eingehen die in erster linie das
rentensystem betreffen auch da sieht es
düster aus das desinteresse der ampel an
der rente dh der altersversorgung
allgemein zeigt sich ja nicht nur an der
leerstelle im koalitionsvertrag selbst
das wenige auf dass man sich einigen
konnte wird im haushalt nicht
sachgerecht abgebildet es gibt es heute
keinen ausgewiesenen titel für das
projekt und rente das war doch einst das
prestige-projekt der spd es gibt bis
heute keine übersicht über die
versicherungsfremden leistungen gut das
hat system vielleicht möchte man das
auch gar nicht so genau wissen aber die
höhe kann ich ihnen sagen und 37
milliarden euro pro jahr und was es auch
nicht gibt die gesetzlich zugesagten 500
millionen euro pro jahr als stabilitäts
zuschuss für die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung
insgesamt zwei milliarden euro einfach
mal so gestrichen die rentenversicherung
hatte bis zum gesetzesentwurf den 500
millionen euro zuschuss in ihrer
finanzplanung mit blick auf die
liquidität als sicheren zuschuss
eingestellt dieses geld und fehlen ja es
fehlt jetzt schon die bundesbank hat
gerade davor gewarnt dass die
rentenversicherung im laufenden jahr ein
defizit von 2,5 milliarden euro
einfahren wird das heißt wir laufen mit
ansage in ein finanzielles desaster
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
nicht der sorgsame umgang mit dem geld
der bürger die nicht mehr erwartet
dieser haushalt ist handwerklich
schlecht gemacht inhaltlich falsch und
angesichts der kommenden
herausforderungen nicht ausreichend
vielen dank
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen andreas odrich
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich fange diese rede heute an mit
einer zahlen nicht einer mit einer zahl
aus den haushaltsberatungen sondern mit
einer zahl die gerade in deutschland
millionen von menschen sorge bereitet
7,9 prozent in dieser höhe lag im mai
die inflation tendenz steigend die
energiepreise und damit auch die
lebensmittelpreise steigen für viele
menschen gerade für menschen in der
grundsicherung gerade für menschen mit
kleinen einkommen in eine höhe die kaum
noch an ein erträgliches maß hat darum
ist es so wichtig dass wir als koalition
die entlastungs paket beschlossen haben
und es ist so wichtig dass wir als
koalition die entlastungs pakete im
ergänzungs haushalt auch finanziert
haben das kostet millionen von euro das
kostet milliarden von euro das ist
richtig um konkret zu sein weit über 30
milliarden sind das und das ist gut
angelegtes geld weil der soziale frieden
gerade in einer so schwierigen situation
die voraussetzungen dafür ist das wird
tatsächlich auch alles andere in dieser
gesellschaft schaffen was notwendig ist
und dabei ist eines klar die bisherige
entlastung ist notwendig und die ist gut
aber wir müssen bereit sein auch künftig
zu handeln der krieg in der ukraine der
wird unerbittlich weiter geführt und wir
erleben derzeit schon dass der diktator
wladimir putin bereit ist
lebensmittelpreise dass er bereit ist
energiepreise zur waffe zu machen wir
müssen damit rechnen dass im herbst ist
einen dramatischen anstieg der gaspreise
gibt einen dramatischen anstieg der
heizkosten gibt und in der folge auch
der lebensmittelpreise das wird zu
tiefgreifenden fragen führen das wird so
tief greifenden fragen der
verteilungsgerechtigkeit führen die
vorstellung dass familien das ältere
menschen dann im herbst im winter in der
kälte sitzen weil sie es sich nicht mehr
leisten können zu heizen ist für mich
inakzeptabel und muss für diese
gesellschaft inakzeptabel seien deswegen
müssen wir deswegen müssen wir bereit
sein auch im herbst das nötige geld in
die hand zu nehmen um dann denen die es
brauchen den sozialen frieden in dieser
gesellschaft zu sichern
wir beschließen heute neben dem haushalt
auch den mindestlohn und das ist eine
gehaltserhöhung auf 12 euro die stunde
für deutlich über sechs millionen
menschen in diesem land sein riesiger
schritt mit dem wir deutlich machen
menschen die in diesem land vollzeit
arbeiten dürfen am ende des monats nicht
von armut bedroht sein das ist
inakzeptabel und das gehen wir mit
diesen mindestlohn an
und wer etwas genauer hinschaut der
erkennt wer vor allem profitiert und
auch da lohnt ein blick es sind frauen
die vor allem profitieren und es sind
menschen in ostdeutschland die
profitieren weil die diejenigen waren
die bislang von prekärer arbeit
besonders betroffen sind und es kommt
eine sache hinzu die oft vernachlässigt
wird die erhöhung des mindestlohns ist
auch ein wirtschaftsprogramm ist ein
wirtschaftlicher motor wir höhen
kaufkraft damit menschen gehen los
menschen haben finanzielle möglichkeiten
menschen wenige innenstädte in die cafés
in die kinos sie kaufen ein und gerade
nach einer 22 jahre in denen wir gesehen
haben wie sehr die innenstädte gelitten
haben unter corona ist dass das
wirtschaftsprogramm was gerade die
kleinen läden die kleinen geschäfte in
den innenstädten jetzt so dringend
brauchen
zwölf euro
mindestlohn ist bitter nötig angesichts
der preisentwicklung ist ein
wirtschaftsprogramm von dem wir alle
profitieren und das ist nicht zuletzt
schlicht und ergreifend eine frage von
respekt von würde von anstand in dieser
in unserer gemeinsamen gesellschaft
unterstützung chancen und ein
würdevoller umgang den haben auch
hunderttausende menschen verdient die
jetzt angesichts des krieges zu uns
kommen und auch ihnen garantieren wir
genau das mit dem haushalt es ist
richtig dass wir den menschen aus der
ukraine zugang zu den sozialsystemen zum
arbeitsmarkt geben und das gute ist wir
müssen uns nicht entscheiden die frage
ob wir diesen menschen helfen ob wir da
unterstützung leisten oder menschen die
schon sehr lange bei uns in der
gesellschaft hier in deutschland leben
diese frage stellt sich nicht wir tun
beides mit diesem haushalt das gute ist
dass wir gleichzeitig sagen zu der
öffnung des arbeitsmarktes für menschen
die aus der ukraine kommen dass wir den
sozialen arbeitsmarkt für menschen die
hier viele viele jahre
langzeitarbeitslos sind sichern und dass
wir ihn stärken das ist ein großartiges
instrument während fristen dieses
instrument fast alle jobcenter in
deutschland nutzen es und mit diesem
haushalt geben wir weiteren spielraum
künftig sind 200 millionen euro
zusätzlich das haben wir hier im
bundestag gemeinsam erreicht 200 euro
million 200 millionen euro zusätzlich an
finanziellem spielraum da um menschen
den weg aus der langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
aufzuzeigen und genau dass sich die
politik drucken nicht gegeneinander
auszuspielen sondern zu sagen wir bieten
chancen für diejenigen die hier
herkommen da haben eine verantwortung
und gleichzeitig kümmern wir uns um die
die hier seit vielen jahren
langzeitarbeitslos sind und bieten all
diesen menschen zukunftsperspektiven
und genau dieser gedanke
trägt uns auch wenn wir die großen
transformationen angehen die vor uns
liegen und die großen umstellungen die
damit in verbindung stehen die haben
gerade erst begonnen
wo heute noch mit kohle mit öl mit gas
gewirtschaftet wird werden wir schon
sehr bald sehen das nur noch nachhaltige
treibstoffe zum einsatz kommen wo heute
fossile energieträger noch der zentrale
bestandteil industrieller produktion
sind werden wir schon bald sehen das
genau die sind diese fossilen
energieträger nicht mehr teil der
produktion sind das sind riesige
umstellen stellung ich kenne das ich
kenne das von vielen zulieferer
betrieben in ganz deutschland die zum
teil ihre produktionsprozesse
grundsätzlich umbauen müssen und an der
stelle bietet der koalitionsvertrag
alles was notwendig ist und was wir
brauchen um zukunft zu schaffen dazu
gehört auch dass wir die bundesagentur
für arbeit zu einer transformation
agentur machen die rein geht die weiß
was vor ort los ist die weiß wo jobs
schwierig werden wo neue jobs entstehen
was wir machen müssen an weiterbildung
von menschen dass die nicht
steckenbleiben auf dem weg sondern dass
die vom einen job in den nächsten kommen
und wir haben diese krisensituation im
blick wir haben intensiv darüber
diskutiert wie wir die bundesagentur für
arbeit stabil halten und für die zukunft
ausstatten können und genau das ist eine
perspektive die wir auch mit blick auf
den haushalt 2023 wieder einnehmen wir
haben die bundesagentur für arbeit im
blick und wir werden dafür sorgen dass
sie gut ausgestattet genau diese arbeit
in zukunft tun
die
entlastungen von menschen in einer
krisensituation und auf der anderen
seite das öffnen von neuen chancen egal
ob es geflüchtete sind egal ob es
menschen in der langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
sind oder ob es menschen sind die in der
großen transformation die wir jetzt
anstehen haben neue chancen suchen all
das sind seiten der gleichen medaille
und all das das zeigen wir heute mit
diesem haushalt haben wir als ampel im
blick und werden auch in den nächsten
jahren genau das angeben dankeschön
sagt andreas orth rage für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen ist er der
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
aber in dem zusammenhang mit dem
einzelplan vielleicht wichtiger
berichterstatter im haushaltsausschuss
für den einzelplan ebenso die nächste
rednerin für die linke gesine lötzsch
die preisexplosion bei energie
lebensmitteln mieten bedroht viele
menschen existenziell
gleichzeitig frisst die inflation die
löhne und gehälter auf und da müssen wir
wirksam gegensteuern meine damen und
herren wir
als linke werden heute der erhöhung des
mindestlohnes auf 12 euro zustimmen aber
wir wissen alle es ist nicht ausreichend
die nächsten schritte müssen folgen
eigentlich müssten es jetzt schon 13
euro sein meine damit herren
der kanzler will nun eine konzertierte
aktion von arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften
zusammengerufen um die lohn preis
spirale zu verhindern ich glaube aber
wir hier im bundestag könnten doch
sofort maßnahmen beschließen es wäre
doch möglich einen bundesweiten mieten
deckel zu beschließen hier heute und
sofort dass wir eine wirksame entlastung
meine damen und herren und wir brauchen
ein weiteres entlastungspaket das diesen
namen auch verdient herr minister hahn
sie sind für die renten zuständig
alleinlebende mit niedriger rente hat
die installation schon jetzt mehr
gekostet als je an entlastung bekommen
werden und wie kann es sein trage ich
sie dass die rentnerinnen und rentner
bei der energie kostenpauschale leer
ausgehen sie aber als minister diese 300
euro bekommen finden sie das gerecht wir
nicht
und fragen sich fragen wo ist der preis
deckel für energie und benzin wie wir
ihn in spanien und portugal sehen das
muss hier auch endlich beschlossen
werden herr minister sie haben ein klima
geld gefordert eine richtige forderung
die wir unterstützen aber die leider von
finanzminister linda sofort wieder
abgeräumt wurde und sie haben natürlich
in ihrem ministerium auch genügend
offene baustellen sie haben nichts
gesagt zum bürgergeld wann kommt das
endlich sie haben nichts gesagt zur
kindergrundsicherung wann kommt die 4
besteht handlungsbedarf meine damen und
herren und wenn sich die spd bei diesem
modell fdp und da müssen sie
gegensteuern bei diesen modellen
durchsetzen will dann werden die
menschen noch weniger geld in der tasche
haben als jetzt und das darf nicht
geschehen meine damen und herren
schon jetzt so viele die situation
unerträglich
der hartz-iv-satz wurde um ganze drei
euro angehoben und für stromkosten
bekommen hat vier betroffene und das
sind nicht nur arbeitslose das sind auch
menschen die mit einem geringen lohn
abgespeist werden diese menschen
bekommen eine pauschale von 36 euro pro
monat aber derzeit zahlt man schon fast
das doppelte wenn man einen neuvertrag
beim günstigsten anbieter abschließen
der paritätische wohlfahrtsverband
fordert die regelsätze deutlich
anzuheben auf
678 euro pro monat diese forderung
unterstützen wir das ist eine forderung
der sozialen gerechtigkeit es ist eine
forderung der chancengleichheit und
darum müssen sie hier endlich
entschlossen handeln vielen dank
hier redet schwagers für die linke ja
das bürgergeld ein vorhaben der großen
koalition das jahr hartz 4 ersetzen soll
und wenn ich dem minister vor richtig
zugehört hat hat er das bürgergeld für
den ersten erst nächstes jahr gekündigt
allerdings es gibt noch keine konkreten
finanzierungsvorschläge und das ganze
muss ja auch noch umgesetzt werden und
erst mal sowieso in der ampel beraten
werden und dann im parlament
dass ich gesagt habe dass wir noch nicht
so viel steuern gezahlt haben war
natürlich ironisch gemeint aber ich
musste als neuling auch erst lernen dass
politik und ironie nicht gut zusammen
geschlossen soviel dazu
so kommen wir zum einzelplan mit diesem
einzelplan 11 dem etat des arbeits und
sozialministeriums beraten wir heute
abschließend ein der zukunft etats im
gesamten bundeshaushalt
zukunft etwa deshalb weil wir in den
kommenden jahren große reformen bevor
stehen haben und wie etwa mit der
einführung des bürgergeldes und auch mit
notwendigen rentenreform wie der
kapitalgedeckten rente weniger
bürokratie und mehr
generationengerechtigkeit schaffen
werden und auch schaffen müssen in den
letzten wochen konnten haben etat des
arbeits und sozialministeriums noch
einige wichtige nachbesserungen
vornehmen die der aktuellen lage
rechnung tragen
insbesondere die freischaffende
künstlerinnen und künstler haben unter
der korona pandemie schwer gelitten die
negativen auswirkungen auf die
künstlersozialkasse konnten durch einen
entlastungszug schuss des bundes in höhe
von gut 84,5 millionen euro der
zusätzlich zum regulären bundeszuschuss
gewährt wurde aufgefangen werden ohne
einen weiteren zuschuss zuschuss würde
der abgabesatz für das jahr 2023
sprunghaft und deutlich ansteigen und
für die versicherten erneut eine hohe
finanzielle belastung bedeuten
daher haben wir auf besonderen wunsch
meiner fraktion einen sogenannten
stabilisierungs zuschuss in höhe von gut
59 millionen euro eingeführt der den
abgabesatz im kommenden jahr ein brems
ein wichtiger schritt für die
versicherten den nur die union die sich
bei der einbringung und dienstag noch
über zu wenig gezielte entlastung
beschwert hatte im ausschuss abgelehnt
hat als liberale politiker war es mit
aber ein besonderes anliegen dass die
mehrausgaben zumindest teilweise über
den einzelplan des berme es
gegenfinanziert werden konnten ich bin
froh dass sich unsere
ampelkoalition hier auf ein
einheitliches vorgehen einigen konnte
und wir uns das ziel gesetzt haben
möglichst alle zusätzlichen vorhaben
kostenneutral umzuschichten
so kommt das geld auch da an wo es
wirklich gebraucht wird und das verstehe
ich unter solide und wirtschaften auch
der ukraine krieg hat große auswirkungen
auf den arbeits und sozialetat weshalb
der ergänzungs haushalt ausgabe mitte
zur verstärkung von von maßnahmen in
höhe von gut 2,4 milliarden euro
vorsieht zwei milliarden euro hiervon
werden benötigt um den rechtskreis
wechsel der geflüchteten in das zweite
sozialgesetzbuch durchzuführen damit
entfallen die sozialleistung nach dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
und es greifen die
grundsicherungsleistung des sgb 2
zuständig sind also in zukunft die
jobcenter den wir höhere finanzielle
spielräume damit ein hohn es ist
besonders wichtig dass wir den
geflüchteten einen schnellen zugang in
den arbeitsmarkt ermöglichen denn
deutschland ist auf zuwanderung
angewiesen gewesen unsere kinder werden
aus und spätestens beim renteneintritt
danken deshalb haben wir über den
ergänzungs haushalt auch weitere 105
millionen euro für die berufsbezogene
deutschförderung und durch das dampft
durch das band zur verfügung gestellt
damit stehen nunmehr 450 millionen euro
zur verfügung die dringend benötigt
werden um die kriegsflüchtlinge aus der
ukraine rasch in den arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren
wer weniger glücklich war ich allerdings
mit der tatsache dass die mit zehn
milliarden euro vorgeschlagen eine
kapitalgedeckte altersvorsorge also die
sogenannte aktion rente aus formalen
gründen noch nicht im bundeshaushalt
2022 berücksichtigt werden konnte
er gut ding will weile haben
in den vergangenen monaten haben wir
viel über zweifelsohne notwendige
rüstungsausgaben debattiert auch über
höhere ausgaben in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit wurde
gesprochen die debatte rund um unser
rentensystem kamen dabei allerdings viel
zu kurz wenn wir verhindern wollen dass
wir nicht schon in zwei jahren die summe
der beitragssätze von
40% knappen wollen dann ist es
allerhöchste zeit dass wir unsere rente
wieder zukunftsfest machen dafür schlägt
mein liberales herz es ist nicht weniger
als eine frage der gerechtigkeit unseren
kindern und enkelkindern gegenüber klar
ist klar ist für uns liberale aber auch
dass unser ziel ab 2023 die im
grundgesetz festgeschriebene
schuldenbremse wieder einzuhalten
höchste priorität
wir müssen ehrlich mit uns seien die
kommenden haushaltsberatungen werden
dadurch nicht leichter es ist aber
unsere pflicht als hüter des geldes
exorbitante schulden explosionen zu
vermeiden
gerade in der aktuellen situation in der
besonders arbeitnehmer von großen
finanziellen belastungen stehen ist
keine zeit für ideologische debatten
über mögliche steuererhöhungen oder eine
höhere staatsverschuldung ganz im
gegenteil deshalb widerstrebt mir auch
ganz besonders das verschwenderische
verhalten der linken besonders über 50
milliarden euro zusätzliche wünsche
allein im einzelhandel einzelplan 11 und
größten teil nicht gegenfinanziert das
ist für mich eine absolut unseriöse
oppositionsarbeit und zeigt den maßlosen
umgang mit unseren steuergeldern so
fehlt für unglaubwürdig
die fdp hat in den letzten wochen
maßgeblich dazu beigetragen dass wir
gemeinsam mit unseren koalitionspartnern
einen ausgewogenen bundeshaushalt
aufstellen konnten lassen sie uns nun
auch gemeinsam zur schuldenbremse
zurückfinden um unseren staatshaushalt
wieder zukunftsfest und
generationengerecht zu machen denn und
das finde ich abschließend erwähnen
wir haben der schuldenbremse zu
verdanken dass wir in den krisen der
vergangenen jahre überhaupt so viele
entlastungs mittel zur verfügung hatten
vielen dank
claudia raffelhüschen basis für die fdp
fraktion ja und sie haben zwischendurch
gesehen hier schön angefangen von der
bildregie dass olaf scholz hier
zusammensteht mit dem
bundesarbeitsminister
und jetzt hören wir mal bärbel bas
martin reichert haben fristgerecht
einspruch gegen die in der letzten
sitzung erteilten ordnungsrufe eingelegt
vize präsidentin göring eckardt hat
beiden einsprüchen nicht abgeholfen die
einsprüche werden als unterrichtung
verteilt gemäß § 39 der geschäftsordnung
sind die einsprüche auf die heutige
tagesordnung zu setzen der bundestag hat
über die einsprüche ohne aussprache zu
entscheiden die entscheidungen über die
einsprüche werden als zusatzpunkte 5 und
6 auf die tagesordnungspunkte römisch
drei bis
das ist circa 12 uhr aufgerufen
und jetzt rufe ich für die cdu zähler
ging es gestern das war ein nachtrag von
gestern gestern gab es von der
bundestags vizepräsidentin katrin göring
eckardt eine ausgesprochene rüge an die
afg abgeordneten diverse bars gerade
genannt hat und da gibt es ein spruch
und wie gesagt das wird heute noch das
parlamentarische verfahren noch einmal
beschäftigen und die mittagszeit aber
wir hören erst mal weiter hier hermann
gröhe jetzt zum einzelplan der vertreter
fraktionsvorsitzender der union seit
beginn der korona pandemie einen
einmaligen stresstest zu bestehen und
wenn wir uns die zahlen der
bundesagentur für arbeit ansehen
dann hat dieser sozialstaat diesen
stresstest bis sehr gut bestanden und
darauf können wir gemeinsam stolz sein
dazu hat maßgeblich beigetragen das
instrument des kurzarbeitergeldes
das schnell geholfen hat das gut
geholfen hat ein teures instrument aber
billiger als arbeitslosigkeit zu
finanzieren
und gerade weil wir auch der
bankschulden in welcher weise tausende
mitarbeiter in die administration von
kurzarbeit neu einsteigen mussten wäre
es angemessen gewesen ihnen nicht nur zu
danken sondern den fehlbetrag im
bundeshaus im haushalt der bundesagentur
für arbeit durch einen zuschuss
auszugleichen und nicht ein darlehen
getätigt zu gewähren es ist schade dass
sich der bundesarbeitsminister da nicht
durchgesetzt hat gegen den
finanzminister und es ist noch
bedauerlicher dass die ampel hier
unserem antrag im haushaltsausschuss
nicht gefolgt ist meine damen meine
herren wir sind in einer situation in
der der arbeitsmarkt sich als robust
erweist in der wir übrigens auch zu
recht im sommer die regelungen das
kurzarbeitergeld auf dem normalen
situation vor der krise wieder
einstellen können es ist aber vor allen
dingen auch eine chance auch
langzeitarbeitslosen auch menschen mit
mehrfachen vermittlungshemmnissen zur
teilhabe durch arbeit zu verhelfen das
ist es was zu allererst
langzeitarbeitslose wünschen wo wir
wichtiges mit dem sozialen arbeitsmarkt
auf den weg gebracht haben diesen weg
gilt es konsequent fortzusetzen
falsch ist es vor der kleinen gruppe
hartnäckig mitwirkungs verweigerer zu
kapitulieren
und deswegen ist die aussetzung von
sanktionen ein völlig falsches signal
und ich betone dass auch weil sie damit
ein vorgriff nehmen wollen auf das
sogenannte bürgergeld und da ist schon
interessant wenn sie in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag davon sprechen dass
bürger geld solle der würde des
einzelnen der einzelnen gerecht werden
ja das ist entweder eine
selbstverständlichkeit und dann muss es
wegen sich soll sondern muss heißen oder
sie machen ich eben doch die lesart zu
eigen wonach in unseren job centern die
würde der leistungsempfänger rinnen und
leistungsempfänger gleichsam
systematisch missachtet wird wir weisen
diesen vorwurf gegen die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
unseren job centern entschieden zurück
sowie langzeitarbeitslose keinen
generalverdacht verdient haben so dass
schulden sie auch respekt denen die mit
ihrer täglichen arbeit diesen
sozialstaat umsetzen und sie schuldet
übrigens auf denen respekt liebe
täglicher arbeit pünktlich erschienen
durch beiträge und steuern den
sozialstaat erst ermöglichen und die
übrigens auch sanktioniert werden wenn
sie einfach nicht themen insofern wissen
sie schon die frage sich stellen wen sie
respekt zolle klar ist die zahlen auf
dem arbeitsmarkt sind gut die zahlen auf
den preisschildern sind dramatisch und
was auf den zapfsäulen und in den
supermarkt regalen steht erschüttert vor
allem die menschen mit kleinen einkommen
aber auch mittlere einkommen sehen mit
entsetzen wie anspar ersparnisse fürs
alter wie eis in der sonne schmelzen die
frage einer wirksamen bekämpfung der
preissteigerung ist die entscheidende
soziale frage in diesem land und da
braucht es eines klugen miteinanders von
sozial finanz und wirtschaftspolitik und
da versagt die ampel in dramatischer
weise
herr heil schlägt vor verheilt schlägt
vor ein soziales klima geld er nimmt ein
wort aus dem koalitionsvertrag dass dort
übrigens etwas ganz anderes meint
nämlich die rückgabe der preise der
steigerung der co2 bepreisung er weiß
dann da doch daraufhin eigentlich
zuständig sei herr hayek und helen aber
er sei verantwortlich
so auf den unterschied von
verantwortlichkeit und zuständigkeit
hingewiesen sagt herr lindner er freue
sich auf finanzierungsvorschläge von
einer der heiland übrigens bisher 1
gemacht herr lindner solle endlich seine
arbeit machen
er nimmt man sagt daraufhin die
vorschläge von heyl passt nicht sinn zu
bürokratisch und im übrigen mache er
steuerfinanzierte umverteilungs töpfe
nicht mit meine damen meine herren der
bundeskanzler spricht von einer
konzertierten aktion gegen
preissteigerung statt eines konzerts
bietet sein eigenes kabinett ein
klägliches stimmengewirr meine damen
meine herren das ist das gegenteil von
einem harmonischen
konzert und wenn sie weiter bei der
preissteigerung versagen dann nützt auch
ein höherer mindestlohn nichts und ich
sage sehr deutlich wir stehen nicht
gegen einen mindestlohn von 12 euro wir
stehen nicht dagegen das haben wir immer
gesagt und im übrigen wenn sie weiter so
versagen bei der preissteigerung ist das
zu wenig aber wir erreichen nicht die
hand für die entmündigung der
sozialpartner und weil sie stolz andrea
nahles zitiert haben als die
mindestlohn-kommission
eingesetzt wurde hat andrea nahles vor
einem politischen mindestlohn gewarnt
weil dieser so andrea nahles wörtlich
der willkür und dem populismus für und
tor öffnet und wenn sie die schlicht
geschichtsklitterung betreiben eine
mindestlohn kommission hat ein cdu
bundesparteitag 2012 vorgeschlagen so
ist es gekommen wir sagen ja zu einem
angemessenen mindestlohn aber nein zur
schwächung der sozialpartnerschaft
herzlichen dank an das heißt im ergebnis
dass die unionsfraktion sich zumindest
wahrscheinlich mehrheitlich wie es
angekündigt enthalten wird wenn es um
die abstimmung haben die erhöhung des
gesetzlichen
mindestlohn und geht ja hermann gröhe
hat es angesprochen das bürgergeld ist
noch sozusagen auf den parlamentarischen
weg allerdings hat die ampel bereits
einen weitgehenden verzicht auf
sanktionen gegen hartz 4 empfänger bei
auflagen verstoßen beschlossen mitte mai
das hatte er ebenfalls angesprochen
katrin michael jetzt für die spd
kollegin jessica
p ja
ich war schon gerade ein bisschen sehr
verwundert was herr gröhe ja geradezu
vom stapel gelassen hat als
gewerkschafterin würde ich natürlich
sofort unterschreiben dass wir immer
gute tariflöhne haben das würde aber
bedeuten dass mehr arbeitgeber und
arbeitnehmer sich den tarif
gemeinschaften anschließen müssen und
dass wir mal in den osten wie da die
quote ist wie viele überhaupt von
tarifverträgen geben können und solange
das so ist brauchen wir einen
mindestlohn das zum anfang
eigentlich wollte mit einem dunk beginn
ein dank an meine mit berichterstatterin
an die sprecher an die referenten an die
mitarbeitenden an das haus von hubertus
heil weil wir haben wirklich in den
letzten wochen intensiv und gemeinsam
und vertrauensvoll in ampel koalition
zusammengearbeitet das macht mut auf
mehr und dafür herzlichen dank
wir reden heute im einzelplan es über
161 milliarden euro kein pappenstiel
161 milliarden euro als investition in
unseren sozialen zusammenhalt der den
kitt unserer demokratie und unseres
sozialstaates bildet und von den 161
milliarden
sind 160 milliarden alleine für die
renten vorgesehen und 42 milliarden euro
für leistungen nach sgb 2 und 3 nur so
viel es ist uns gelungen für den etat
arbeit und soziales im vergleich zum
regierungsentwurf
zusätzlich 963 millionen einzustellen
und mit der ausgewogenen finanzierung
dieses einzel plans sorgen wir dafür
dass das bundesministerium für arbeit
soziales und auch die nachgeordneten
behörden erfolgreich seine aufgaben
nachgehen können dazu gehört im kern
eine gezielte arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitik um anlassbezogen und
flexibel reagieren zu können aber auch
im besonderen vorausschauend agieren zu
können ziel dabei ist es dass so viele
menschen wie möglich einer
erwerbstätigkeit nachgehen können und
ziel ist es dass in der arbeitswelt
faire bedingungen gelten und der
arbeitsschutz den hohen anforderungen
nach sicherheit und gesundheitsschutz
rechnung trägt und obwohl sich die
rahmenbedingungen permanent ändern
müssen sich die menschen in einer
alternden gesellschaft auf den
sozialstaat verlassen können der
sozialstaat muss die für lebensrisiken
schützen und verlässlich bleiben und
damit der sozialstaat leistungsfähig und
verlässlich bleibt müssen wir klug
haushalten ja kluge haushaltspolitik
bedeutet für mich vorausschauend und
nachhaltig zu handeln
finanzen daraus zu geben wo es am
nötigsten ist aber auch da zu sparen wo
es möglich ist und wir übernehmen mit
diesem haushalt verantwortung für alle
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
aber gerade und besonders für diejenigen
die auf unsere unterstützung angewiesen
sind wir übernehmen mit diesem haushalt
verantwortung dafür dass die zeitenwende
finanziell und sozial sicher gestaltet
werden kann und wir übernehmen
verantwortung für diejenigen die bei uns
zuflucht suchen
100 tage krieg putin
führt ihnen
verabscheuungswürdig gegen die ukraine
und er ganz allein trägt die schuld
dafür dass mehr als 6,5 millionen
menschen ihre heimat verlassen müssen
mehr als 600.000 haben bisher zuflucht
in deutschland gesucht putins krieges
lieferketten stoppen energiepreise und
lebenshaltungskosten in die höhe
schnellen und die sorge dass erneut in
größerem ausmaß arbeitsplätze in gefahr
sein können ist allgegenwärtig und auch
wenn vom arbeitsmarkt gegen dadurch
positive signal ausgehen müssen wir
vorbereitet sein und darum ist für
unsere volkswirtschaft existenziell dass
wir das kurzarbeitergeld weiter
vorhalten
auch der demokratische wandel und der
überall zu tage tretende
fachkräftemangel erfordern weiterhin
größter anstrengung und darum ist es so
wichtig und für uns auch ein großer
erfolg dass wir für die eingliederung
von langzeitarbeitslosen
veranschlagten 400 millionen euro um 200
millionen auf nun 600 millionen euro
erhöhen konnten
die menschen können sich sicher sein den
sozialstaat an ihrer seite zu haben denn
in summe haben wir zehn milliarden euro
zur verfügung gestellt damit
arbeitssuchende schnell wieder in lohn
und brot kommen und darüber hinaus
fließen 105 millionen euro zusätzlich
aus dem ergänzungs haushalt für die
berufsbezogene deutsch sprachförderung
sodass in summe 450 millionen euro zur
verfügung stehen um denjenigen die aus
der ukraine zu uns fürchten müssen die
möglichkeit zu geben schnell unsere
sprache zu lernen das ist eine wichtige
voraussetzung für eine zügige
integration in unseren arbeitsmarkt und
übrigens grundlage dafür dass diese
menschen auch demnächst qualifikation
anständig und fair bezahlt werden
ein besonderes anliegen war uns die
unterstützung der künstlersozialkasse
meine mit berichterstattenden haben das
schon ein
darauf bezug genommen denn in der tat
die künstlerinnen und künstler sind ganz
besonders von der krise von der panne
betroffen gewesen und es war uns ein
herzensbedürfnis sie jetzt zusätzlich
mit 59 millionen euro zu unterstützen
damit eben der abgabesatz abgabesatz für
die sozialversicherung stabilisiert wird
und
berichterstattungen der ampel liegt auch
der hp2 von ganz besonders am herzen
bislang konnten sich leider die
bundesländer noch immer nicht auf einen
beitrag zur finanzierung einigen wir
halten im haushalt einen titel vor um
einen gerechtigkeit beitrag für jene
menschen zu leisten die durch den
rentenüberleitung der nachwendezeit
nachteile erlitten haben und kürzlich
habe ich mich gemeinsam mit meinen
bericht mit meinen mit
berichterstattenden an alle
ministerpräsidenten der länder gewandt
und sie nachdrücklich um unterstützung
dieser angelegenheit gebeten eine
einigung in dieser sache schnell wie
möglich herbeigeführt werden sie ist
längst überfällig und die betroffenen
erwarten völlig zu recht eine lösung und
das er vorgestern als übermorgen
aus vor den menschen lösen wir heute ein
zentrales versprechen ein und
beschließen die erhöhung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro ja viel zu
viele menschen werden noch mit
niedriglöhnen abgespeist und wir haben
es vorhin gehört es ist jeder fünfte
davon profitiert und nur einmal mit ganz
genauen zahlen zu arbeiten
in meinem heimatland kreis bautzen sind
das 33.500 person
33.500 personen die davon profitieren
das sind 26 prozent der
arbeitnehmerinnen nur um das mal
darzustellen für uns ist ganz klar
sozialer zusammenhalt und gute arbeit
für uns priorität gerechte löhne
auskömmliche renten und soziale teilhabe
sind die voraussetzungen für ein gutes
und selbstbestimmtes leben diesen fokus
werden wir ganz klar auch für die
kommenden haushaltsverhandlungen
beibehalten herzlichen dank und glück
auf
ktm michel war das für die
sozialdemokraten
ja insgesamt
profitieren zwischen sechs und sieben
millionen arbeitnehmer von der erhöhung
des gesetzlichen mindestlohns
rené springer für die afg jetzt
[Applaus]
auch präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe gäste man kann
über den sozialhaushalt nicht
debattieren ohne nicht über zwei
zentrale problemfelder zu sprechen die
sie hier regelmäßig ignorieren und auch
heute wieder geschickt umtänzeln das ist
einmal die inländer feindlichkeit der
bundesregierung und das ist auf der
anderen seite die auswirkung navigation
bezogen auf den explodierenden
sozialhaushalt hier
merkt jetzt illegale grenzöffnung ist
nun sieben jahre her und schauen wir auf
die zahlen sehen wir das heute 900.000
menschen aus den top 8 also
herkunftsländern hartz 4 beziehen das
sind die hälfte alle migranten aus den
top 8 also herkunftsländern 400.000 sind
in beschäftigung 200.000 1000 davon den
unter qualifizierten jobs und wenn man
das umrechnet stellt man fest dass auf
eine fachkraft aus diesen ländern für
sozialhilfeempfänger kommen und sie
ändern hat dieser politik überhaupt
nicht sie machen einfach weiter so und
meine damen und herren dass es nichts
anderes als staatlich organisierte
veruntreuung von steuergeld
die rechnung dafür bezahlen die
arbeitnehmer in diesem land die
arbeitnehmer die nach oecd-angaben die
zweithöchste belastung mit steuern und
abgaben weltweit tragen
und anstatt die nun zu entlasten die es
verdient haben bauen sie gerade unseren
sozialstaat radikal um und führen ein
grundeinkommen für asylbewerber ein
asylbewerber sollen zukünftig nach
vorstellung der bundesregierung direkt
in hartz 4 durchmarschieren können das
bedeutet ein rundum sorglos versorgung
inklusive klassenfahrt für die kinder
inklusive und um versicherung in der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherung und
dann gibt's obendrauf auch über das
entlastungs paket der bundesregierung
auch noch eine einmalzahlung von 200
euro meine damen und herren oben drauf
kommt dann auch noch dass die sanktionen
abgeschafft werden für
hartz-iv-empfänger das heißt wenn jemand
die teilnahme an einem deutschkurs
ablehnt eine berufliche qualifikation
ablehnt oder eine zumutbare arbeit dann
bleibt das zukünftig ohne konsequenzen
es gibt also einen freifahrtschein für
hartz4 empfänger und das wollen die
damen und herren ist ein nackenschlag
für aldi mindestlohn empfänger in diesem
land die am ende des monats trotz eines
vollzeitjobs oftmals weniger eine tasche
haben als ein hartz 4 empfänger
und obendrauf obendrauf auch diese ganze
last auf die koffer die getragen werden
kommt jetzt noch die inflation
arbeitnehmer haben momentan werden
erdrückt von der höchsten inflation seit
den 70er jahren seit der ölkrise jeder
siebte muss sich höher verschulden jeder
zweite sorgt sich inzwischen um seinen
lebensunterhalt und die einzige antwort
die bundesregierung hierzu bieten hat
sind 300 so einmalig als entlastung und
diese 300 euro müssen auch noch
versteuert werden das ist ein witz meine
damen und herren diejenigen die den
laden hier am laufen halten die ihnen
die 10.000 euro diäten im monat
finanzieren und ihnen herr minister die
30.000 euro die sie im monat bekommen
die lassen sie jetzt bei der inflation
ins offene messer laufen und
die rentner und die rentner haben sie
gleich völlig vergessen eine mutter mit
drei kindern bekommt in deutschland oder
alle mütter mit drei kindern bekommen in
deutschland durchschnittlich eine rente
von 751 euro denken sie darüber nach 751
euro durchschnittlich ein legaler
migranten in deutschland lebt hat
zwischen 800 und 1000 euro hartz 4
anspruch der migrant bekommt 200 euro
einmalig aus dem entlastungspaket und
die mütter in rente bekommt nichts gar
nichts sie sollten sich schämen hier im
haus das sie das mittragen
und das ist nichts anderes als inländer
feindliche politik nichts anderes
das haus brennt durch die inflation das
haus brennt durch die inflation und sie
kippen jetzt obendrauf auch noch ein
brandbeschleuniger denn die
bundesregierung hat kraft eigener
wassersuppe entschieden aus dem öl
embargo auszusteigen das heißt also kein
öl mehr aus russland kein öl mehr nach
leuna kein öl mehr nach schwedt russland
verkauft derweil sein öl nach asien und
macht sogar noch mehr profite weil der
ölpreis steigt meine damen und herren
die folge wird sein dass benzin und
diesel in ostdeutschland in deutschland
insgesamt teurer werden dass die
versorgungssicherheit gefährdet wird und
dass vor allem zehntausende jobs
gefährdet sind und herr minister heil
ich erwarte eigentlich von ihnen dass
sie nach schwedt fahren und nach leuna
fahren und die beschäftigten dort
erklären warum sie zu kanonenfutter in
einen krieg werden den russland
wahrscheinlich gewinnen wird ganz
einfach fahren sie hin und erklären sie
das den leuten diese leute verlieren
ihren arbeitsplatz umsonst
meine damen und herren die inländer
feindliche politik der bundesregierung
ist nicht alternativlos wir haben als
alternative für deutschland mehrere
vorschläge unterbreitet schon im oktober
letzten jahres was man besser machen
kann entlasten sie die arbeitnehmer
erhöhen sie pendlerpauschale senken sie
die mehrwertsteuer auf sprit gas und
heizöl damit das fahren und das tanken
wieder bezahlbar ist reduzieren sie die
mehrwertsteuer bei lebensmitteln auf
null damit man es essen wieder bezahlen
kann und vor allem stoppen sie die
gelddruckerei und niedrigzinspolitik der
europäischen zentralbank
ganz zum schluss
stoppen sie die wirtschaftssanktionen
gegen russland wir schießen russland
vielleicht in einen knie wir schießen
uns aber in beide knie das kann nicht
das ziel einer interessengeleiteten
deutschen politik sein dankeschön
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen beate
müller-gemmeke
herr springer ihre hetze ist widerlich
und unerträglich
erklärte präsidentin sehr geehrter herr
minister liebe demokratinnen und
demokraten
zum ersten oktober wird er nun definitiv
kommen der mindestlohn in höhe von 12
euro das ist notwendig denn der
mindestlohn ist die unterste haltelinie
und die macht nur dann sinn wenn die
beschäftigten in vollzeit auch
tatsächlich davon leben können mit dem
neuen mindestlohn heben wir also rund
sechs millionen beschäftigten über die
armutsschwelle der niedriglohnbereich
wird damit wieder ein stück weit kleider
und genau dieses ziel verfolgen wir
schon lange
die arbeitgeberseite sieht das wenig
überraschend anders auch in der anhörung
wurde wieder erzählt die erhöhung per
gesetz sei ein schwerwiegender angriff
auf die tarifautonomie und kollegen sie
sprechen ja von schwächung der
sozialpartner von entmündigung das
gegenteil ist aber der fall im unteren
lohnbereich ist ihnen dies die
tarifautonomie gar nicht mehr existent
hier gibt es kaum noch tarifverträge und
das führt auch dazu dass die löhne dass
die menschen von ihrem lohn nicht mehr
leben können und dass das die löhne auch
schon gar nicht mehr zur absicherung im
alter reichen und wenn sich immer mehr
und mehr arbeitgeberinnen von der
tarifautonomie
verabschieden wenn es immer weniger
tarifverträge im unteren bereich denn
die die arbeitgeber immer weniger
tarifverträge im unteren bereich
abschließen dann muss die politik eben
eingreifen und politisch die untere
haltelinie anpassen nicht die erhöhung
des mindestlohns sondern die flucht aus
der tarifbindung ist ein angriff auf die
tarifautonomie
irgendwann kommen auch genau zur
richtigen zeit der angriffskrieg von
putin und jetzt trainer abhängigkeit von
fossiler energie aus russland lassen
eben die lebensmittel- und energiepreise
steigen kleine einkommen schaffen das
nicht mehr deshalb entlasten wir ja die
menschen mit verschiedenen maßnahmen und
auch der neue mindestlohn wird an dieser
stelle helfen und entlasten bei
mindestlohn geht es uns grünen aber vor
allem um gerechtigkeit denn arbeit muss
fair entlohnt werden und auch vorarbeit
armut schützen alles andere in einem so
reichen land wie unserem einfach nicht
akzeptabel
der mindestlohn gibt es aber nur im
doppelpack mit dem mini jobs natürlich
wissen wir dass es hier große probleme
gibt viele mieterinnen wissen zum
beispiel gar nicht genau welche rechte
sie überhaupt haben und deshalb
versuchen wir auch gerade bei der
umsetzung der eu transparenzrichtlinie
noch weitere verbesserungen zu erreichen
und wir wissen auch dass es für
beschäftigte minijob und das sind vor
allem frauen nicht wirklich attraktiv
ist in
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung zu wechseln und deshalb
glätten die jetzt die hürde im und
übergang zudem zu den midi jobs das ist
wichtig denn viele frauen wollen
eigentlich aus dem minijob und mehr
arbeiten und genau das werden wir
natürlich
unterstützen und ermöglichen
wir haben um das gesetz aber wirklich
abzurunden müssen vor allem auch noch
die geplanten und notwendigen
steuerlichen verbesserungen auf den weg
gebracht werden wir werden definitiv die
steuerklasse 5 abschaffen da und damit
den wechsel hin in reguläre
beschäftigung attraktiver machen und
damit ist jetzt die fdp am zug und ich
freue mich darauf in möglichst bald ein
entwurf aus dem finanzministerium vor
liegt aber jetzt heute freue ich mich
erst einmal dass endlich das sich
endlich über 12 euro mindestlohn
abstimmen darf und dann bringen wir als
nächsten schritt wirklich ein bundes
tariftreuegesetz auf den weg vielen dank
werte müller gemmeke war das für die
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und
hinten grünen hatten die forderung nach
zwölf euro gesetzliche mindestlohn auch
in ihrem wahlprogramm stehen nicht nur
die spd für die linke spricht deren
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
seine fesche
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
als linke kämpfen seit vielen jahren für
die erhöhung des mindestlohns auf 12
euro und deswegen stellen wir heute dem
gesetz der bundesregierung auch zu
aber wenn sie fällig wären wenn es wenig
wären würden sie das gesetz nicht nur
mindestlohn erhöhungs gesetz sondern
auch prekäre beschäftigung ausweitung
gesetze nennen denn sich verstecken
hinter diesem schönen namen die
gleichzeitige ausbeutung von mini-jobs
und das lehnen wir entschieden ab
und darüber hatten wir heute auch
getrennt und namentlich abstimmen denn
wahlkampfversprechen sind das eine aber
wie heißt so schön an den taten werdet
ihr sie erkennen
und es ist mittlerweile mehrfach belegt
mini jobs verdrängen reguläre jobs sie
sind nicht sozial abgesichert man kann
von ihnen nicht leben und insbesondere
frauen verbleiben nach wie vor in der
teilzeit verletzt minijobs sind und
bleiben
arbeitsmarktpolitisch und
gleichstellungspolitischen völliger
irrweg
der preis für die erhöhung des
mindestlohns also sehr hoch sorgen sie
als bundesregierung dann wenigstens
dafür dass die zwölf euro bei den
menschen auch angekommen millionen
beschäftigt wir werden schon jetzt um
den ihnen zustehenden lohn betrogen und
um das deutlich zu machen dass das
bedeutet wir reden hier über
beschäftigte mit aus schönen die selbst
um die mickrigen 9 eur 82 der stunde
noch geprellt werden und das ist doch
wirklich skandalös und
sie glauben doch nicht im ernst
dass bei einer erhöhung dann weniger
betrogen wird das gegenteil wird der
fall sein deswegen brauchen wir mehr und
wirkungsvollere kontrollen
und ich habe mit kolleginnen und
kollegen der finanzkontrolle
schwarzarbeit gesprochen das sind
diejenigen die für die kontrollen
zuständig sind gefragt das braucht ihr
für eure arbeit und sie haben gesagt sie
brauchen eine tagesaktuelle
manipulationssichere
arbeitszeiterfassung genau das was sie
wieder aus ihrem gesetzesentwurf
rausgestrichen haben damit nehmen sie
mindestlohn betrug belegten den kaufen
das ist völlig inakzeptabel meine damen
und herren
und angetestet derjenigen die hier immer
rum nön und behaupten die erhöhung des
mindestlohns sei ein eingriff in die
tarifautonomie eine kurze erklärung
warum wir eine gesetzliche
lohnuntergrenze brauchen es war die
politik einer ganz großen schwampel ja
sie waren alle daran beteiligt von rot
über grün über gelb bis nach schwarz die
prekäre beschäftigung gefördert und die
gewerkschaften geschwächt hat und
deswegen ist es jetzt nötig dass wir
eine lohnuntergrenze haben
und brauchen
deswegen ist es auch notwendig dass die
anvisierte konzertierte aktion nicht
dazu führt dass man gewerkschaften
wieder lohnverzicht predigt weil wir
brauchen genau das gegenteil wir
brauchen ordentliche lohnerhöhung
bei aller kritik abschließend der
mindestlohn müsse erhöhung ist eine gute
sache legen sie jetzt bei den kontrollen
nach unsere vorschläge dazu finden sie
in unserem antrag und dann haben sie uns
auch hier als unterstützung an ihrer
seite vielen dank
ja so seine fesche hat nochmal begründet
dass es wird nachher als tatsächlich
eine geteilte abstimmung geben wenn es
mir das mindestlohngesetz geht weil die
linke eine teilung beantragt hat weil er
nicht einverstanden ist mit der
ausweitung der minijobs
mit der ausweitung der
geringfügigkeitsgrenze beim mini jobs
und ganz genau zu sagen lukas köhler
jetzt für die fdp
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meiner
lieben damen und herren wir
diskutieren einen großen haushalt aber
wir diskutieren ja vor allen dingen in
dieser zeit unheimlich viel über die
zeitenwende das ist ein sehr breiter
begriffs viel genutzt von jeden und sehr
ausgiebig immer wieder fotos hat einen
großen weiten kontext aber dass die
zeiten sich in der sozial und
arbeitsmarktpolitik wenden das ist schon
länger der fall und das ist es worauf
wir uns vorbereiten müssen und das ist
es wo die ampel mit diesem
bundeshaushalt aber auch mit den
unterschiedlichen gesetzen die jetzt
vorliegt gerade den richtigen weg ein
geht nämlich den weg zu mehr
nachhaltigkeit den weg zu einer besseren
sozialpolitik zu einer gerechteren
sozialpolitik aber auch zu einer
sozialpolitik die dem einzelnen die
möglichkeit schafft aufzusteigen weil
das ist es am ende was die leute wollen
und darauf freue ich nicht dafür kämpfen
wir und das muss ich sagen macht auch
viel spaß mit den koalitionären
wir sehen aber auch es gibt einen
gigantischen druck auf das sozialsystem
gesehen wie viel gelder aktuell nötig
sind und wir sehen vor allen dingen wie
der demografische wandel sich in den
nächsten jahren auswirken wird und
deswegen müssen wir uns darauf
vorbereiten die systeme tragfähig zu
machen und dazu gehen wir heute die
ersten schritte das ist gut wir haben
mit dem nachholfaktor in der rente ein
system für die nachhaltigkeit die wir
jetzt einführen werden und die dafür
sorgt dass die renten zumindestens auch
für kommende generationen noch nicht
perfekt sind aber dass die steigerung
der beiträge nicht ins uferlose aussagen
und der das ziel dass dabei besteht und
das ist ja die frage der solidarität und
gerechtigkeit gegenüber allen menschen
auch gegenüber kommenden generationen
das hat uns das bundesverfassungsgericht
mal festgestellt dass wir auch
nachhaltigkeit gegenüber kommenden
generationen walten lassen müssen das
ist ein richtiger und wichtiger schritt
es gibt noch andere
gute punkte die heute hier auf die hier
aufgeschrieben werden und die wir heute
durchbringen werden aber ich bin schon
etwas verwirrt frau
und frau versteht sie haben ja gerade
das problem beschrieben der
tarifautonomie und die frage diskutiert
sozusagen mit dem mit der erhöhung des
mindestlohns würde damit diese
tarifautonomie aufgehoben der punkt ist
nicht dass wir einen mindestlohn
einführen damit haben wir auch als fdp
unseren frieden gemacht es ist auch
jetzt richtig und logisch dass wir
weiterhin den mindestlohn haben das
problem ist aber und das ist die
herausforderung der angesprochene
überbietungswettbewerb und das problem
ist dass haben sie voll in ihre rede
eben dargestellt sie haben nämlich schon
jetzt gesagt ja zwölf euro reicht nicht
wir brauchen 17 glaube ich war s wir
brauchen weitere 18 19 und der
überbietungswettbewerb den wir hier
immer wieder auf den plan bringt er
entsteht dadurch dass man eben politisch
steuern will wie hoch der minister dies
ist jetzt wir auch da haben wir unseren
frieden mitgemacht dem weg gegangen
worden
nicht mehr in verhandlungen den nächsten
schritt zu machen an einer stelle aber
wir haben auch dafür gesorgt dass das
nicht weiter der fall sein wird und das
ist auch richtig so wir haben aber vor
allen dingen etwas zweites gemacht wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass nach neun
jahren das erste mal wieder die mini-
und midijobs die grenzen angehoben
werden so dass die leute mehr geld
verdienen können und nicht weniger
arbeiten müssen so dass menschen dass
sie über sie millionen menschen in
deutschland jetzt eine bessere
perspektive haben mehr geld verdienen
können dass diese menschen ist endlich
hinbekommen und dazu braucht es die fdp
war das letzte mal war auch unter fdp
regierung dass wir das hingekriegt haben
dass dieses menschen sie jetzt besser
gehen wird und das ist der weg in den
aufstieg wir haben eine zeitenwende am
arbeitsmarkt die menschen können
arbeiten sie wollen arbeiten und wir
müssen sie dazu bringen und dazu
befähigen das zu tun das tun wir an
dieser stelle das tun wir mit diesem
haushalt das tun wir aber auch die ganze
zeit und das ist der richtige weg
deswegen vielen herzlichen dank
lukas köhler stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der liberalen ja
und zwangsläufig so zu sagen hat die fdp
in den koalitionsverhandlungen im jahr
schon zugestimmt dass die ampel den
mindestlohn auf 12 euro erhöhen wird für
die fdp gab es dann sozusagen den
aufschlag im gegenzug für die besetzung
der geringfügigkeitsgrenze und auch das
ganze jahr flexibel in zukunft zu
gestalten sollte der mindestlohn weiter
ansteigen
eine der wichtigsten aufgaben der
politik ist die schaffung von vertrauen
die bürgerinnen und bürger müssen darauf
vertrauen können dass er stark mit
augenmaß in ihrem sinne handelt sie
müssen darauf vertrauen können dass wir
als abgeordnete unser möglichstes tun
ihre an bedingungen für gute arbeit zu
schaffen gute arbeit das bedeutet nicht
nur faire bezahlung
sondern auch sichere arbeitsplätze der
kassierer die kellnerin die
reinigungskraft die küchenhilfe der
friseur alle haben zu recht die
erwartung von ihrer arbeit leben zu
können das ist soziale marktwirtschaft
und auf
und genau aus diesem grund hat die
unionsgeführte bundesregierung
2015 die bayer heil den gesetzlichen
mindestlohn eingeführt ziel war und ist
der schutz der arbeitenden bevölkerung
vor lohndumping
und dies
[Applaus]
dies geht auch und gerade in der
momentanen situation
mit den deutlich gestiegenen preisen
wird der einkauf oder die stromrechnung
zu einer großen belastung für viele in
unserem land insbesondere
geringverdiener und deshalb ist eine
lohnuntergrenze von zwölf euro pro
stunde auch richtig
soziale marktwirtschaft bedeutet aber
auch dass löhne nicht vom staat geregelt
werden die tarifautonomie ist in
deutschland im grundgesetz verankert und
genau deshalb war uns bei der einführung
des mindestlohns wichtig diesen von den
sozialpartnern gemeinsam in einer
politisch unabhängigen kommission
verhandeln zu lassen der staatliche
eingriff in die tarifautonomie sollte
einmalig sein
aus gutem grund sollten löhne nicht
politisiert werden und da lohnt es sich
dieses zitat von der ehemaligen
bundesarbeitsministerin andrea nahles
übrigens ihres zeichens ehemaliger spd
vorsitzende zu wiederholen sagte ein
politisch festgelegter mindestlohn würde
zitat willkür und populismus tür und tor
öffnen und recht hat sie denn wenn wir
uns auf diesem weg einlassen können wir
überbietung geschäfte von spd grünen und
linken in den nächsten wahlkämpfen
erwartungen ich bin dankbar dass der
kollege köhler das eben auch erwähnt hat
zumindest bei der fdp herrscht diese
einsicht denn was bedeutet das einen
überbietungswettbewerb würde bedeuten
dass über kurz oder lang arbeitsplätze
gefährdet werden hören und das leben
wieder ab denn das wäre weder im sinne
der arbeitnehmer noch der arbeit
kollegen glauben sie eine zwischenfrage
oder zwischenbemerkungen aus der
fraktion die linke
die behalte ich bin ihnen sehr dankbar
dass sie ihre rede noch einmal
unterstrichen haben wie wichtig
vertrauen ist und ich muss festhalten
damals hat die spd versprochen den lohn
nicht politisch festzulegen und heute
bricht die spd dieses versprechen
deshalb und genau deshalb haben wir
einen entschließungsantrag eingebracht
wir erwarten von der ampel eine
klarstellung dass dies ein einmaliger
vorgang ist darauf müssen die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
vertrauen können denn es geht auch darum
dass die entscheidungen von heute nicht
die arbeitsplätze von morgen gefährden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen laut
deutschland trend von gestern muss sich
fast die hälfte aller menschen in
deutschland aufgrund der inflation stark
einschränken und entscheidend ist
deshalb auch dass am ende des tages mehr
geld im portemonnaie übrig bleibt sie
muss also bereit nicht mehr passieren
zum beispiel eine wirksame anpassung der
einkommensteuer da könnte sich mal
unseren antrag dann schauen da steht
alles drin und wenn ich mich recht
erinnere waren die kollegen von der fdp
auch einmal dafür und wir sitzen so
einigermaßen erstaunt darüber dass die
fdp bei diesem fundamentalen
systemwechsel mitmacht aber sie haben
sich selbst zu bewerten dass ihnen das
vertrauen ihrer wählerinnen und wähler
wert ist
hier zum nun wollen dass die bürgerinnen
und bürger guten gewissens darauf
vertrauen können dass wir die
rahmenbedingungen für gut bezahlte und
sichere arbeitsplätze schaffen und genau
deshalb sagen wir voller überzeugung ja
zu 12 euro mindestlohn aber ein klares
und kraftvolles nein zur politischen
löhnen vielen dank
naomi klein hat hier noch mal
geschrieben das ist ja eine debatte
schon angeklungen der union wird also
jede mindestlohn der erhöhung nicht
zustimmen sie hat einen eigenen
entschließungsantrag pro gelegt und
möchte das ist nun mal schriftlich
fixiert das klargestellt dass zukünftig
die festlegen dass mindestens die er
sich die mindestlohn-kommission
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
viele vor mir haben es bereits gesagt
die preise und längst nicht mehr nur die
energiepreise steigen viele bürgerinnen
und bürger insbesondere mit kleinen
einkommen familien mit kindern menschen
die besonders belastet sind alle sie
haben schon und der der pandemie ganz
besonders gelitten und tun das jetzt
umso mehr viele haben angst um ihre
zukunft
um unsere zukunft insgesamt und viel zu
viele müssen sich die frage stellen ob
das geld noch für obst die fahrt zur oma
das heizen oder den schulausflug reicht
was wir also brauchen um gut durch diese
krise zu kommen ist als allererstes ein
starker gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt
und soziale stabilität die hoffnung für
die zukunft gibt was wir brauchen ist
mehr soziale gerechtigkeit
und liebe freundinnen und freunde von
der unionsfraktion eine gesellschaft in
der niemand zurückgelassen wird wenn der
wind mal schärfer bläst in der alle
mitgenommen werden das geht eben nicht
mit appellen und nicht mit sonntagsreden
sondern es erfordert politisches handeln
wir müssen das kommt noch
wir müssen wir müssen diese soziale
frage unserer zeit beantworten und das
tun wir und das haben wir schon in der
vergangenheit bewiesen dass auf uns
verlass ist mit den überbrückungshilfen
haben wir unternehmen geholfen mit der
kurzarbeit konnten hunderttausende
arbeitsplätze gerettet und die einkommen
stabilisiert werden im übrigen wurde
damit auch die basis für die anstehende
rentenerhöhung gelegt das fällt eben
nicht vom himmel und das regelt auch
nicht der markt sondern das ist allein
politisches handeln
deswegen habe ich dich auch angeguckt
und das tun wir jetzt auch mit den
entlastungs paketen 1 und 2 und das sind
1 und 2 und das sind 30 milliarden gut
investierte euro zum beispiel in eine
vierköpfige familie mit geringen
einkommen die allein durch den
kinderbonus die energie pauschale um
rund 650 euro entlastet wird und das ist
wichtig und richtig so
und auch heute handeln wir wieder und
beschließen den mindestlohn zum ersten
oktober auf 12 euro zu erhöhen
ich hatte diese woche und das war sehr
schön endlich wieder schülergruppen aus
meinem wahlkreis zu besuch unter anderem
eine abschlussklasse der
theodor-heuss-schule
azubis die rechtsanwalts- und
notarfachangestellte
wären sie haben mir erzählt dass wenn
sie dieses jahr nach ihren prüfungen in
ihren beruf einsteigen dann werden sie
von den zwölf euro mindestlohn von
unserer mindestlohn erhöhung profitieren
denn bisher liegen die gehälter für sie
meistens deutlich unter 12 euro drei
jahre anstrengende und fordernde
ausbildung und dann mit weniger als
zwölf euro in den beruf einsteigen dass
es unanständig
und auch deswegen ist es gut dass wir
mit den zwölf euro eine neue anstands
untergrenze für löhne in deutschland
einführen wir erhöhen damit das
einkommen von sechs millionen menschen
wer vollzeit zum mindestlohn arbeitet
verdient bisher brutto der minister hat
es gesagt rund 1700 euro dann rund
2100 das ist eine lohnerhöhung von 22
prozent und trotz hoher inflation ein
echter
kaufkraftzuwachs ein mindestlohn von 12
euro ist aber mehr als das wir lösen
heute eine zusage ein versprechen ein
mehr respekt mehr respekt für diejenigen
die tag für tag dafür sorgen dass der
laden läuft die große leistung für
kleines geld die dafür sorgen dass es
uns gut geht und dass wir bekommen was
wir brauchen verkäuferinnen und
verkäufer helferinnen helfer in der
landwirtschaft paketboten friseurinnen
und friseure und viele viele andere mehr
deswegen
die erhöhung des mindestlohns ist ein
akt der notwehr gegen sinkende
tarifbindung und unanständige löhne wer
vollzeit arbeitet muss davon in
deutschland auch gut leben können
aber er kroes' 12 euro mindestlohn sind
nicht das ende unserer vorstellung wir
wollen wieder mehr tarifbindung in
deutschland und auch das geschieht
leider nicht ohne politisches handeln
deswegen haben wir im koalitionsvertrag
aufgeschrieben öffentliche aufträge des
bundes werden zukünftig nur an die
unternehmen gehen die nach tarif
bezahlen richtig so lohndumping darf
eben kein wettbewerbsvorteil sein und so
stärken die tarifpartnerschaft
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der krieg
wird morgen nicht vorbei seien die
energiepreise werden kurzfristig nicht
wieder sinken und die hohe inflation
wird noch ein stück weit anhalten dazu
kommen die herausforderung durch die
transformation unserer industrie durch
die digitalisierung und durch den umbau
unserer energieversorgung
es ist an der zeit dass wir nicht nur
von heute auf morgen denken sondern ein
langfristig wirkendes instrument
entwickeln das die kosten der
veränderung hin zu einer zukunftsfähigen
und klimaneutralen wirtschaft und
gesellschaft abfedert und gerecht
verteilt deswegen bin ich sozialminister
für seinen vorschlag eines sozialen
klima geldes außerordentlich dankbar ein
soziales klima geld sozial gestaffelt
für alle singles mit einem einkommen
unterhalb 4000 und bei paaren unterhalb
8000 euro denn wir liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir brauchen das geld nicht das
geld muss dort ankommen wo es besonders
gebraucht wird bei den kleinen bei den
mittleren bei den normalen einkommen
und ich bin mir sicher dass unser
finanzminister wie im entlastungs paket
beschlossen schnellstmöglich eine aus
zahlungsmöglichkeit über die steuer id
schaffen wird dafür schon mal ein
herzliches dankeschön wir wollen unser
land unsere demokratie krisenfest machen
durch gute zukunftsfähige arbeit und mit
einem starken sozialstaat der den
bürgerinnen und den bürgern den rücken
stärkt und freiheit und das leben ein
wenig leichter macht ich freue mich
darauf in der ampel weiterzuarbeiten
glück auf
madita war das für die spd fraktion und
der mindestlohn der heute beschlossen
wird übrigens haushalterisch ist ja gar
nicht teuer ist ein recht günstiges
projekt für den staat summiere das denn
die hauptlast tragen die unternehmen und
der staat verdient sogar noch sozusagen
bekommt geld bundesminister heil rechnet
mit einem plus von 1,4 milliarden euro
im jahr aufgrund des höheren
mindestlohns beispielsweise weil höhere
sozialbeiträge gezahlt werden ich muss
ganz offen ausdrücken das ist nicht der
dass ich nur unter einem
parlamentarischen diskurs vorstelle aber
vielleicht müssen sie uns ja auch
einfach diffamieren um davon abzulenken
dass sie nach 16 jahren führend in der
koalition das wohlstands versprechen für
die bürger in deutschland nicht mehr
einlösen und die abwehr macht es noch
komplett kaputt wir als afd wir stehen
jedenfalls dafür dass man sich von
seiner hände arbeit tatsächlich noch ein
ganz gutes leben leisten kann dass man
eine familie gründen kann und dass man
die familie auch ernähren kann und
dieses wohlstand verspreche das wird von
ihnen leider zunehmend gebrochen wie wir
sehen an den statistiken die hälfte der
leute wissen nicht mehr wie sie herum
kommen sollen drei viertel im unteren
einkommensschicht mentor das immer genau
beim thema des gesetzentwurfs den
mindestlohn den sie auf 12 euro per
gesetz erhöhen wollen und auf der einen
seite ist das in gewisser weise richtig
weil wir haben eine sehr hohe inflation
dank der gelddruckerei der ezb und es
ist in gewisser weise angemessen auf 12
euro hoch zu gehen aber es ist
gleichzeitig natürlich sehr gefährlich
denn wenn wir einen gesetzlichen
mindestlohn haben der so stark steigt
dann treiben sie natürlich auch die nun
preisspirale dann werden die preise und
noch weiter steigen und man wird von
zwölf auf 14 15 gehen das ist nicht die
lösung des problems sieht doch dann an
einem symptom herum und wissen sie warum
wir überhaupt mindestlohn brauchen
schnell das liegt insbesondere daran
dass schon die schwarz-rote koalition
aber sie auch millionen leute
hunderttausende e gala migranten ins
land geholt haben deren lohn perspektive
natürlich genauso bodenlos ist wie ihr
qualifikationsniveau und weil es dann
eine entsprechende konkurrenz auf dem
arbeitsmarkt insbesondere der
niedrigeren qualifiziert und jetzt geht
natürlich der lohn für alle nach unten
und dann kommt natürlich wieder ihr
sozialistischer korrektiv gedanke das
dürfen wir nicht zulassen davon da kann
man nicht leben also brauchen wir einen
mindestlohn ich sage ein gesunder markt
bräuchte keinen mindestlohn ein gesunder
markt hat nämlich regeln und er hat
grenzen und deswegen brauchen wir
entsprechend grenzen für unseren
arbeitsmarkt in unsere sozialsysteme und
wir brauchen auch ein ende dieser
inflation und das geht mit einer währung
die auch grenzen hat wir dürfen nicht
den euro retten wurde retex wir müssen
den wohlstand unserer bürger retten
logitech soll dafür steht die afg
und es hilft auch nichts die die die
auswüchse des sozialstaats zu kassieren
kaschieren wie sie das im mini- und
midijob bereich versuchen was ist es
denn anderes als dass beim minijob im
endeffekt es so aussieht für den
arbeitnehmer als würde er keine
sozialversicherungsbeiträge zu zahlen
haben ja die zeit halt dann der
arbeitgeber dafür umso mehr aber wissen
sie was die sozialbeiträge die werden
nicht niedriger dadurch dass man sie
kaschiert sondern wir werden nur dann
niedriger wenn wir zusammen eine politik
machen dass steuern und abgaben sinken
dass die löhne steigen das hier
rausgehen aus einem euro der uns
verdammt das hier reingehen in eine
währung die uns stark macht das bringt
produktivität das bringt wachstum und
das bringt wieder wohlstand für alle in
unserem land haben sie herzlichen dank
während der bundestag hier den letzten
einzelplan des haushaltes debattiert
kann ich ihm noch mal weil dieser tag ja
doch sehr außergewöhnlich ist einen
kleinen zeit überblick geben also die
abstimmung hier zum einzelplan und zu
mindestlohn wird so ungefähr in einer
halben dreiviertel stunde beginnen dann
das muss ja namentlich sein weil es eine
teilung der abstimmung gibt dafür zu
gehen wir später noch mal kommen gegen
kurz nach 12 wird es dann hier die
schlussrunde für das haushaltsgesetz
2022 geben gegen 14 uhr dann die debatte
zu dem 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr und
der entsprechenden grundgesetzänderung
die einen sind für das deutsche reich
und die anderen sind für reiche deutsche
wir haben jetzt in wien beide varianten
gehört dafür steht die fdp
zu den zu den richtigen problem wir
haben den krieg in der ukraine und die
folgen hier auch zu bewältigen große
herausforderung auch für die
arbeitsmarkt- und sozialpolitik und wir
haben ja auch noch die klimakrise und da
hat uns vor ein paar wochen eine studie
erstreckt die aufgezeichnet was die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass dieser kipp
punkt die 15 grad schon bald erreicht
werden sie interessiert das überhaupt
nicht ich weiß das aber das ist für alle
anderen ist das ein wichtiges über
lebensthema die grundlagen das
gleichgewicht olympische gleichgewicht
droht ins kippen zu kommen und das
vielleicht sogar schon in fünf jahren
das heißt wir werden massive
anstrengungen brauchen um diesen
ökologischen umbau hin zu kriegen um die
klimakatastrophe tatsächlich zu
verhindern und er hat arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitik eine ganz wichtige rolle
weil wir werden den ökologischen umbau
nur hinkriegen wenn das sozial gerecht
vonstatten geht und
wir haben jetzt heute ein gesetz
verabschieden der bei dem wir einen
wichtigen ersten schritt machen wir
beschließen die anhebung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns auf 12 euro
und das ist in der tat ein großer und
wichtiger schritt denn wer vollzeit
arbeitet muss einen lohn erhalten der
über der armutsschwelle liegt lange lag
der lange lag der mindestlohn im
europäischen vergleich ganz weit unten
wir waren da ganz weit hinten in der
rangliste und jetzt nähern wir uns den
60 prozent was als angemessener
mindestlohn gilt und damit beschließen
wir ein wichtiges mittel zur eindämmung
des niedriglohnsektors in deutschland
und ja auch ich habe hier am pult und
auch früher als wissenschaftler immer
wieder betont wie wichtig die
mindestlohn-kommission ist und das ist
auch nach wie vor richtig so aber ich
sage ihnen vor allen dingen von der
union auch wenn wir es nicht schon einen
koalitionsvertrag gehabt hätten dann
wäre doch spätestens an mit bei diesen
hohen inflationsraten ist richtig hier
im bundestag und jetzt zu beschließen
dass der zu niedrige mindestlohn auf 12
euro erhöht werden das ist ja auch ein
wichtiges mittel um die inflations
folgen zu bekämpfen
und das ist ein einmaliger schritt das
haben wir auch immer gesagt und in
zukunft ist dann wieder die mindestlohn
vision gefragt und was uns grünen
wichtig ist dass dabei aber auch mit
berücksichtigt wird dass damit auch die
armut bekämpft wird weil der mindestlohn
muss auch vor armut schützen
aber anhebung des mindestlohns ist ja
nicht das einzige für gute löhne wir
wollen die tarifbindung stärken das geht
dieses jahr schon los wir haben
entlastungspaket gemacht wurde
erwerbstätige besonders unterstützt
haben durch die energiepreis pauschale
über alle einkommensgruppen hinweg
entlasten insbesondere geringe und
mittlere einkommen und zur wahrheit
gehört aber auch dass weitere handlung
besteht für nichterwerbstätige für
rentnerinnen und rentner für studierende
für auszubilden und auch bei der
grundsicherung braucht es weitere
finanzielle unterstützung und dass wir
zu beachten sein wenn es angesichts der
anhaltend preissteigerung nötig sein
wird ein weiteres entlastungs paket zu
schnüren mit gezielten entlastung für
die die es am dringendsten brauchen und
dafür werden wir uns einsetzen
folge dem haushalt geben der auch gute
signale nur noch zwei beispiele weil ich
nicht mehr so viel zeit habe die
aufstockung der mittel für den sozialen
arbeitsmarkt und die zusätzlichen mittel
für die künstlersozialversicherung da
wir setzen schwerpunkte wo besonderer
handlungsbedarf besteht und sorgen für
mehr soziale sicherheit und das ist erst
der anfang wir werden noch in diesem
jahr das gesetz zur bürgerinnen und geld
beschließen mit dem wir ab dem nächsten
jahr hat vier überwinden können bis
spätestens
und spätestens nächstes jahr wollen wir
einen gesetzentwurf haben zur
kindergrundsicherung frau bis ende
nächsten jahres das ist ein bisschen
komplizierter und dann folgt aber die
kinder grundsicherung um für alle kinder
das existenzminimum zu garantieren
und wir wollen deutschland zu einer
weiterbildungs republik machen mit dem
bildungs mit der bildungs zeit und einem
weiterbildungsgeld ziel der ampel
koalition ist es die menschen in sozial
ökologischen wandel zu unterstützen und
ihnen die existenzängste zu nehmen dem
die nicht zuletzt auch die anhebung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns über die wir
heute beschließen
wir bitten um zustimmung von allen
demokratischen parteien zu diesem
projekt vielen dank
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
pascal kober
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen neben der
verabschiedung des haushaltes für das
für den arbeitsbereich arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitik können wir uns heute über
die erhöhung und die dynamisierung der
minijob grenze freuen sage und schreibe
seit neun jahren seit 2013 ist sie
einzementiert bei
450 euro und das bedeutete das für viele
menschen in unserem land die
lohnsteigerungen nicht mit mehr geld in
der eigenen tasche einhergingen sondern
lasse ihre arbeitszeit reduzieren
mussten jetzt lernen wir die minijob
grenze erhöhen auf 520 euro wären sie
dynamisieren zukunft und das ist eine
gute botschaft für sechs millionen
menschen in diesem land liebe
kolleginnen
amüsieren bedeutet dass wir sie künftig
an die höhe des mindestlohns koppeln
wert mit jeder anhebung des mindestlohns
wird künftig auch die minijob grenze
steigern und ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist eine gute nachricht für
all diejenigen die sich in kleinem
umfang etwas dazuverdienen wollen die
wenige stunden in der woche arbeiten
wollen es ist aber auch eine gute
nachricht für viele unternehmen und
branchen die nur durch die mini-jobs
ihre stoß und randzeiten abdecken können
das sollten wir alle nicht vergessen
wenn wir zu jeder tageszeit volle regale
in den supermärkten vorfinden wenn wir
am wochenende frische brötchen beim
bäcker kaufen können oder wenn wir am
abend im restaurant noch bedient werden
und ihre frau dr laudert sie haben den
fachkräftemangel
angesprochen dann ist aber auch zu
verstehen dass diese erhöhung der
minijob grenze längst überfällig ist
weil sie ein mittel dafür ist dass
arbeitszeit ausgeweitet werden kann und
damit dem fachkräftemangel im kleinen
umfang jedenfalls etwas entgegengesetzt
werden kann und sie sind seit 2013
mitglied im deutschen bundestag seit
2013 haben sie bei der minijob strengste
nichts getan auch das sollte hier
gemerkt
kollege boberow gestatten sie eine frage
oder bemerkung
gerne
den reihen der unionsfraktion
hubert dass sie die zwischenfrage zu
lassen ich verstehe ja dass sie als
mitglied der fdp-fraktion sich
insbesondere über die reformen der mini
und midijobs in diesem gesetz freuen
nachdem aber jetzt schon ihre beiden fdp
vor gegner und auch sie bisher noch
nichts zu mindestlohn gesagt haben würde
ich gerne hörte ich würde ich gerne eine
kommentar von ihnen entlocken
so
also
weil es ein zitat ist frau kollegin es
ist ein zitat von ihrem kollegen herrn
vogel der am 13 dezember 2017 von diesem
punkt folgendes gesagt hat was aber auf
gar keinen fall passieren darf ist dass
wir hier eine politisierung der
lohnfindung bekommen dass wegen des
mindestlohns ist doch dass die höhe in
der hand der tarifpartner in der
mindestlohn kommission verbleibt erstens
weil es schon grundsätzlich richtig ist
dass wir hier keinen politischen
überbietungswettbewerb bei den lohn
hüllen bekommen und zweitens weil sonst
irgendwann arbeitsplätze gefährdet
werden hakuba ich frage sie deshalb hat
ihr kollege vogel unrecht oder haben wir
mit unserer kritik die auch mein kollege
gröhe vorhin vorgetragen hat recht
sehr geehrter herr kollege whitacre ist
schön dass sie sich so gut vorbereiten
dann hat die union 2014 einer
politischen festsetzung eines
mindestlohns bereits einmal zugestimmt
um danach eine mindestlohn kommission
arbeiten zu lassen insofern ist das was
sie uns hier vorwerfen bereits in ihrer
eigenen geschichte geschehen da sind sie
in keiner weise jungfräulich ich möchte
ihnen dazu noch sagen das wesen dieser
koalition ist es fortschritt zu wagen
und fortschritt wagen hier und
fortschritt erhalten dadurch
dass wir
uns gegenseitig die gegeben und nicht
nur dinge nehmen und damit schaffen wir
es dass natürlich projekte auch der
koalitionspartner eingang finden in
einen koalitionsvertrag und auch in die
gesetzliche umsetzung die nicht das
herzensanliegen eines jeden in dieser
koalition sind es war nicht das
herzensanliegen der spd oder grünen die
minijob grenze zu erhöhen aber mit
dieser koalition sind fortschritt
schritte möglich und das war in 16
jahren bei ihnen eben nicht der fall und
deshalb glaube ich erwartet hatte in
diesem land profitieren von dieser
koalition auf den wählerinnen und wähler
der union
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wenden wir uns einem der wichtigsten
projekte dieser legislaturperiode zu der
reform der grundsicherung wir werden sie
nicht nur mit einem anderen namen
versehen sondern wir haben ja auch einen
anderen geist geben denn in zukunft wird
die nachhaltige vermittlung im
mittelpunkt dieser grundsicherung stehen
die wir neu auf die füße stellen werden
wir werden nicht mehr nur in
beschäftigung vermitteln sondern wir
werden qualifiziert um nachhaltige
beschäftigung zu ermöglichen damit
menschen auch langfristig eine
perspektive haben auf ein
selbstbestimmtes leben und
liebe kollege hermann gröhe sie haben
sich ja auch intensiv vorbereitet auf
die debatte indem sie also die
unterschiedlichsten äußerungen in dieser
koalitionsregierung zitieren konnten
aber dann müssten sie auch so fair sein
sich einmal mit dem beitrittsvertrag zu
beschäftigen und da würden sie sehen das
auch die neue grundsicherung das
bürgergeld mitwirkungspflichten haben
wird und wenn sie gut informiert sind
dann wissen sie auch dass nach diesem
sanktionsmoratorium natürlich auch diese
mitwirkungspflichten bis zu 30 prozent
sowie zu ihrer letzten regierungszeit
sanktioniert werden können insofern ist
der alarmismus den sie hier versuchen
loszutreten völlig fehl am platz es geht
darum grundsicherung so in zukunft zu
gestalten dass die menschen eine chance
haben in den arbeitsmarkt einzutreten
und im arbeitsmarkt aufzusteigen
zu diesem neuen geist der grundsicherung
gehört es eben auch dass wir mit einem
ganz anderen und neuen blick auf die
menschen schauen wir werden den
eingangsbereich in der grundsicherung
dadurch prägen das in einem
kompetenzfeststellungsverfahren die
menschen von ihren kompetenzen von ihren
möglichkeiten von ihre chancen her
begriffen werden und nicht von ihren
defiziten wir haben ein optimistisches
menschenbild und das wird sich in dieser
bürger in dieser in dieser bürgergeld
der form auch wiederfinden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und kolleginnen und kollegen wir werden
den sozialstaat auch präventive
ausrichten wir werden versuchen das
problem schon gelöst werden bevor sie
sich verhärten das beginnt natürlich
auch schon in der förderung von kindern
aus sozial benachteiligten familien wir
werden den so genannten paragrafen 16h
ausweiten damit auch schon kinder im
jüngeren lebensalter von
unterstützungsleistungen erreicht werden
können das ist wichtig denn wir wollen
keinen zurücklassen und so früh wie
möglich die menschen unterstützen wir
müssen die jugend berufs agenturen
ertüchtigen das ist auch übrigens eine
frage des datenschutzes da sollten wir
noch mal darüber reden auch mit den
ländern ob es wirklich notwendig ist die
an allen ecken und enden den datenschutz
in den mittelpunkt zu stellen denn es
ist am ende wichtig dass schulen und
sozialstaat miteinander kooperieren
können damit die jungen menschen ist
eine chance haben damit die sozialhilfe
systeme von nod erfahren können und
entsprechend frühzeitig darauf reagieren
können wir sind gespannt auf das was wir
gemeinsam gestalten können in dieser
ampel pohlig weise liebe union sie sind
es auch wir freuen uns auf die debatten
in den nächsten sitzungen
vielen dank
pascal kober war das der sprecher für
arbeitsmarkt- und sozialpolitik der
liberalen und die bundestags
vizepräsidentin petra pau die jetzt die
sitzungsleitung hat uns in den nächsten
redner hierauf mag ja das für die union
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen alles wird
teurer die preise steigen und der
geldbeutel der leute wird immer schmaler
doch von der regierung komme nur
unüberlegte vorschläge die am ende nicht
einmal gegenfinanziert sind der haushalt
des bundesministeriums für arbeit und
soziales ist mit mehr als 160 milliarden
euro der größte aller ministerien
jeder fünfte euro fließt an minister
hubertus heil
doch statt geld vernünftig zur
entlastung der menschen einzusetzen
bekommen wir im wochentakt neue
versprechungen aus denen am ende leider
nichts wird richtig ist den wohlstand
den wir heute großzügig verteilen möchte
muss erst erwirtschaftet werden herr
minister
und was machen die sie wollen ein
bürgergeld einführen sie wollen hartz4
sanktionen abschaffen und ganz neu das
soziale klima geld wenn es um neue
ausgaben geht werden sie kreativ herr
minister bei der frage der finanzierung
bleiben sie allerdings sehr sehr vage
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
diese regierung hat sich als fortschritt
kreation gefeiert doch schon heute sehen
wir dass diese schulden koalition in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen wird doch die
ironie an ihrer angeblichen fortschritt
koalition ist dass sie an ihrem ganzen
wahlversprechen nur deshalb festhalten
können weil wir als union in den letzten
16 jahren mit der schwarzen null dafür
gesorgt haben dass deutschland überhaupt
solide finanzen hat
pläne gibt es viele aber wie diese
bezahlt werden das lassen sie offen die
das angekündigte an
entlastungspaket entpuppt sich als
belastungspaket studenten leiden unter
den hohen treffen und sie entlasten sie
nicht rentner leiden unter den hohen
preisen und sie entlasten sie nicht
pendler leiden unter den hohen preisen
und sie entlasten sie nicht seit
vergangenem wochenende gibt es einen
weiteren vorschlag herr minister ich
habe es gerade eben erwähnt sie wollen
das soziale klima geld einführen nicht
irgendwann sondern bereits ab anfang
nächsten jahres doch davon wusste der
finanzminister wohl nichts und hat den
vorschlag wenige stunden später auch
gleich wieder einkassiert
auch die angekündigte einführung vom
bürgergeld steht nur in den sternen in
diesem haushalt ich habe nichts gesehen
steht nichts drin auf alle fälle hat
sich der minister bemüht die hartz4
sanktionen schnell auszusetzen um den
weg für ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen freizumachen dass liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lehnen wir als
union strikt ab
im haushalt von minister heil finden sie
nur unkonkrete konzepte aber keine
antworten auf die brennenden
herausforderungen vor denen unser
arbeitsmarkt steht während wir einen
massiven fachkräftemangel haben schafft
die ampel mit dem sanktionsmoratorium
das prinzip von fordern und fördern auch
dabei sagt der arbeitsminister noch im
jahr 2018 er selbst dagegen das prinzip
aufzuheben herr heil das hilft
vielleicht der spd-basis aber ganz
sicher nicht im deutschen arbeitsmarkt
ihre prioritäten sind völlig falsch
gesetzt
deshalb schlagen wir vor
sprechen sie in der koalition erst mal
miteinander bevor sie unabgestimmte
pressestatements zu neuen vorhaben und
ideen verbreiten hören sie endlich auf
mit diesem ampel gesamte setzen die die
richtigen prioritäten
entlasten sie endlich studenten pendler
und rente statt immer mehr kleinen
erwarten die bürgerinnen und bürger mehr
planbarkeit daran werden wir auch sie
messen liebe ampelkoalition vielen dank
das wörther doktor martin rosemann für
die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
der russische angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine erschüttert und beschäftigt uns
alle die damit verbundene zeitenwende
forderte unsere außen- sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik heraus dieser krieg
fordert uns aber auch im inneren unserer
gesellschaft heraus erschüttert unsere
werte freiheit und demokratie ja
verlangt humanitäre verantwortung für
die flüchtlinge die vor dem krieg
fliehen
erfordert von uns die abhängigkeit
gegenüber russischen rohstoffimporten
und generell von fossilen brennstoffen
schneller zu überwinden und vor allem
auch eher belastet mit preissteigerungen
vor allem bei den energiekosten unsere
bürgerinnen und bürgern meine damen und
herren die koalition handelt wir haben
zwei entlastungs paket im umfang von
fast 30 milliarden euro auf den weg
gebracht wir konzentrieren uns auf
diejenigen bei denen das geld ohnehin
vorher schon knapp war und die sich
fragen wie sie sich das leben eigentlich
noch leisten können und während der
oppositionsführer friedrich merz am
mittwoch hier gefordert hat zur
finanzierung der bundeswehr den soli für
die kleinen und mittleren einkommen
wieder einzuführen schaffen wir die eeg
umlage ab erhöhen lieber marc beer dass
die pendlerpauschale
zahlen eine energie kostenpauschale für
beschäftigte haben einen
heizkostenzuschuss für wohngeldempfänger
und bafög empfänger auf den weg gebracht
erweitern übrigens die
anspruchsberechtigten beim bafög mache
die größte bafög erhöhung der letzten
jahre und haben eine einmalzahlung für
kinder und grundsicherungsempfänger
beschlossen das heißt zum beispiel für
familien mit zwei erwachsenen und zwei
kindern in der grundsicherung eine
einmalzahlung von immerhin 600 euro dazu
dazu haben wir den kinder sofort zum
schlag und 20 euro pro monat und kind
auf den weg gebracht der erste schritt
zur kindergrundsicherung
respekt und sozialer fortschritt das ist
das versprechen dieser ampel koalition
daran halten wir uns deshalb werden wir
das rentenniveau über
2025 hinaus sichern das ist da ein
zentrales versprechen des sozialstaats
dass wir damit erneuern
deshalb werden wir die
kindergrundsicherung einführen damit
kinder frei von armut in deutschland
aufwachsen können und deshalb werden wir
das neue bürgergeld einführen das auf
augenhöhe unterstützt das übrigens
mitwirkungspflichten vorsehen wird und
deshalb fördern und fordern natürlich
bei behält aber das fördern verbessere
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
darauf kommt es an und deswegen im
übrigen auf viel zustimmung in den
jobcentern stößt der koalitionsvertrag
meine damen und herren sieht ein klima
geld vor weil wir die energiewende
sozial gerecht umsetzen wollen zur
finanzierung stehen die einnahmen aus
dem co2 ist bereit und ich bedanke mich
bei minister hubertus heil deshalb für
seinen vorschlag für ein soziales klima
geld heute
heute beschließen wir die erhöhung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns zum ersten
oktober auf zwölf euro für alle ohne
ausnahme und ohne übergänge und wer ja
sagen will zu den 12 euro der muss dann
auch ja sagen zu einem weg wie man zu
den zwölf euro kommt und muss dem gesetz
noch zustimmen
anstatt sind hier so enthalten
dieser schritt bedeutet eine anhörung
von über 20 das bedeutet aspect für
arbeitsleistung für diejenigen die sich
für wenig geld jeden tag anstrengend und
es ist ein wichtiger beitrag um die
preissteigerungen bewältigen zu können
und meine damen und herren wir schließen
heute auch die größten rentenerhöhungen
seit jahrzehnten mehr als fünf prozent
im westen und mehr als sechs prozent im
osten auch das ist verdient und eine
frage des respekts
da nicht damit zusammen beschließen wir
eine erhöhung der erwerbsminderungsrente
für diejenigen die zwischen 2001 und
2008 10 in die erwerbsminderungsrente
gegangen sind für diejenigen die von den
verbesserungen der vergangenen jahre
nicht profitiert haben ein thema zu dem
ich mit ihnen die meisten bürger briefe
erhalten habe und lange für eine lösung
gekämpft habe und deswegen ist es ein
meilenstein über den ich mich sehr freue
heute meine damen und herren
millionen ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
sind auf der flucht über 500.000 in
deutschland wir haben eine humanitäre
verantwortung das sind überwiegend
frauen
überwiegend mit guter ausbildung
viele folgen hier arbeiten und sich
einbringen und unser interesse ist dass
sie ihre qualifikationen und fähigkeiten
hierauf einsetzen können und deswegen
ist es richtig dass wir die flüchtlinge
ins sgb 2 geholt haben damit sie in den
jobcentern unterstützung wie aus einer
hand oder aus einer hand bekommen und
damit in gesellschaft und arbeitsmarkt
integriert werden können der haushalt
gehen wir heute beschließen schafften
finanziellen voraussetzungen dafür für
die jobcenter aber auch bei den
sprachkursen und mein dank gilt an die
berichterstatter koalitionen den michel
andreas outfit und claudia rath mission
dafür dass sie sich hier eingesetzt
haben ich danke aber auch
danke aber auch hubertus heil und
bettina stark watzinger ihre initiative
bei einer schnelleren anerkennung von
abschlüssen voranzukommen ich hoffe dass
das eine initialzündung ist für
unbürokratische
anerkennungsverfahren
aber auch dafür flexibler auch
bestehenden kompetenzen aufzubauen das
hilft menschen die zu uns kommen aber
auch menschen die schon hier sind denn
fachkräftemangel und arbeitskräftemangel
sind das größte wachstums hindernis das
wird sich in den kommenden jahren
verschärfen
denn uns gehen in jedem jahr durch die
geburtenstarken jahrgänge 400.000
verloren und es werden wir durch
einwanderung mit lesen müssen und
deswegen bin ich froh dass die ampel
gesagt hat ja wollen wir sind ein
einwanderungsland
gerufen haben und natürlich weiter
sprechen tun es aber jetzt auf kosten
ihrer kollegen aber das wird ich komme
zum endet auch präsidentin aber das wird
nicht reichen sondern wir müssen auch
die inländischen potenziale heben durch
weiterbildung durch prävention und
rehabilitation in dem ältere länger im
arbeitsleben bleiben können das ist die
aufgabe dieser ampel koalition ein
sozialstaat zu machen der den
beschäftigten hilft damit wir nicht
gleichzeitig arbeitslosigkeit und
fachkräftemangel produzieren sondern
alle eine perspektive bekommen daran
arbeiten wir weiter vielen dank
martin rosemann arbeitsmarkt und
sozialpolitischer sprecher der
sozialdemokraten
und gibt ja noch einige andere projekte
abgesehen von mindestlohn
bürgergeld ist schon angeklungen
mehrfach in der debatte die nächste
rednerin für bündnis 90/die grünen
stefanie öffne
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist schon
interessant was wir heute hier so alles
über das bürgergeld aus den reihen der
union zu hören bekommen was wir denn
dort alles angeblich tun ja wir haben
uns vorgenommen mehr fortschritt zu
wagen und dazu gehört auch ein aufbruch
in der frage von sozialer gerechtigkeit
aber das was sie hier tun sie spielen
ganz bewusst gruppen gegeneinander aus
indem sie behaupten mit dem was wir
vorhaben würden wir die mitarbeiterinnen
in den jobcentern für schlechte
mitarbeiter/innen erklären das gegenteil
ist der fall an dieser stelle es geht um
die frage welche strukturen nutzen sie
verändern und nicht wie müssen wir
menschen an dieser stelle verändern den
mitarbeiterinnen in jobcentern können
ihren auftrag nur so gut erfüllen die
wir als politik in tatsächlich auf
gestalten und genau das ist unser
anliegen an dieser stelle das zu
verändern dass es um nachhaltige
vermittlung in arbeit geht und es ist
sehr spannend wie sie auch in den
anhörungen zum sanktionsmoratorium immer
wieder aus der ib studie kritisiert
haben die wichtig denn sanktionen sind
um menschen in arbeit zu bekommen
das ist eine interessante lebensweise
einer studie in dem ich nur teil 1
verwenden und teil 2 weglassen dort
steht nämlich dass es kurzfristig
vermittlungserfolge gibt
langfristig gibt es sehr wohl auch nach
teilung diesem aspekt unterschlagen sie
in der debatte immer wieder
[Applaus]
nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir auch die
andere seite beim bürgergeld uns
anschauen nämlich die passiven
leistungen was erhalten menschen an
grundsicherung und die entwicklung
seitdem wir diesen koalitionsvertrag
unterschrieben haben hat uns noch einmal
viel drastischer vor augen geführt wie
enorme belastung menschen gerade die von
armut betroffen sind durch die pandemie
erlebt haben wie sie und wie sich das
noch einmal verstärkt hat durch den
angriffskrieg von putin eine inflation
mit 7,9 prozent ist so hoch wie noch nie
seit der wiedervereinigung für
lebensmittelpreise wird sogar mit einem
anstieg von über zehn prozent gerechnet
und deshalb ist es gut dass er mit dem
entlastungspaket 'nen und den
niederlegung 'nimm ergänzungs haushalt
eine ganze reihe von entlastungen
beschlossen haben die meine kolleginnen
hier alles schon dargestellt haben klar
ist aber auch
das versprechen des bürgergeldes auf
würde und gesellschaftliche teilhabe
lösen wir alleine damit noch nicht ein
wir müssen uns ganz grundsätzlich
gedanken machen über die regelsätze und
dafür will ich nur zwei beispiele nennen
im mobilitäts hat sind 40 eur 27
vorgesehen bei mir in pforzheim kostet
die monatskarte für eine sohn alleine 57
euro da bleibt am ende des geldes noch
ziemlich viele monat über zum zweiten
volk die höhe der regelsätze immer den
kreisen zum vorjahr und selbst wenn wir
davon ausgehen dass
der bedarf damit gedecktes mit so laufen
wir doch mit jeder preissteigerung die
wir im laufe eines jahres haben in eine
unterdeckung des existenzminimum die zum
ende des jahres immer höher wird ich
freue mich das mit dem vorschlag von
hubertus rey jetzt etwas auf dem tisch
liegt wie wir die regelsätze verändern
können aber um das einzulösen und die
heute hier viel zitierte zeit am ende
tatsächlich zu gestalten müssen wir die
auch in der polit aus halls politik
umsetzen denn während mit dem
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr eine
kreditfinanzierung ermöglicht wird wird
die schuldenbremse für die ganzen
sozialen fragen nicht aufgehoben und
auch das ist ein ziel was putin versucht
schon über jahre spaltung in unsere
gesellschaft zu tragen was noch einmal
und sein kalkül passt durch die
preissteigerungen die wir jetzt erleben
und deshalb müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
die erforderliche zeitenwende auch in
der haushaltspolitik erfolgt zumindest
mit einem aussetzen der schuldenbremse
auf 20 23 und eine über grundsteuer
er sagt stefanie öfter von den grünen
allerdings da muss man wohl nochmal mit
dem koalitionspartner sprechen denn fdp
finanzminister lindner hat ja mehrfach
angekündigt dass die schuldenbremse im
nächsten jahr wieder eingehalten werden
soll tatsächlich fragen sich so manche
sozial und arbeitsmarktexperten in der
koalition wie das dann mit den sozialen
projekten aussieht im nächsten jahr wie
viel öl es jetzt für die cdu csu
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren kolleginnen
und kollegen sehr geehrte gäste auf den
besuchertribünen
wer bestimmt wie hoch der lohn sein kann
welcher lohn ist auskömmlich und wer
kann sich vielleicht alles daran
beteiligen dass die menschen auch
wirklich genug geld in der tasche haben
das sind entscheidende fragen die
natürlich auch mit dem hier auch heute
zu beratenden gesetz zum mindestlohn mit
der erhöhung des mindestlohns auf 12
euro durchaus einmal zu fragen sind wir
als cdu bundestagsfraktion und das sage
ich hier sehr deutlich sind sehr für
auskömmliche löhne und es ist uns ein
wichtiges anliegen dass die menschen
auch gut verdienen am liebsten sogar
auch mehr als zwölf euro allerdings ist
der weg dorthin deutlich zu beanstanden
wir haben damals als wir die
mindestlohn-kommission eingeführt haben
bzw mindestlohn eingeführt haben fest
vereinbart dass eine einmalige
gesetzgeberische festlegung des
mindestlohnes geben sollte und dass dann
die weiterentwicklung in die hände der
mindestlohn kommission gelegt wird warum
in die hände der mindestlohn kommission
weil wir es damit in die hände der
tarifpartner legen dort wo
lohnentwicklung auch stattfindet und
stattfinden soll und mit dem heutigen
mit der heutigen erhöhung verlassen sie
von der ampelkoalition diesen weg den
man damals gegangen hat und man stellt
sicherlich von ihrer seite auch in frage
ob die tarifpartnerschaft in der
mindestlohn kommission dann wirklich der
richtige weg ist oder ob sie das in
frage stellen denn
natürlich muss es das ziel sein dass wir
rahmenbedingungen schaffen damit die
menschen möglichst viel geld in der
tasche haben aber da sage ich ganz
deutlich dazu das ist nicht als einzig
und allein eine frage der
lohnentwicklung sondern auch eine frage
wie sich der staat vielleicht daran
beteiligen kann durch die lohnerhöhungen
kommt jetzt natürlich eine erhöhte
steuereinnahmen und höhere abgaben in
die sozialkassen hinein und der staat
macht sich an der stelle einen schlanken
fuß war der den weg mit steuersenkungen
oder senkungen von abgaben eben nicht
geht und das ist insoweit nicht redlich
weil sich der staat hier auch daran
beteiligen könnte die arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer zu entlasten und vor
allem sollte er wert darauf legen die
inflation zu bekämpfen
darüber hinaus
ist an dem gesetz ebenfalls kritisieren
dass natürlich die schwellenwerte bei
der dokumentation angehoben werden
natürlich muss dokumentation und
kontrolle des mindestlohns seien
überhaupt keine frage aber den schwellen
der dorf 4100 euro anzuheben ist doch
etwas vermessen wenn man dabei davon
ausgeht dass man 29 arbeitstage oder 408
348 arbeitsstunden zugrunde legt und
damit wird natürlich dann auch der demo
der bürokratische aufwand erhöht der
nächste punkt minijob und midijob grenze
zu erhöhen sicherlich zu begrüßen bei
520 euro wäre nach unserer auffassung
noch luft nach oben gewesen mit einer
grenze von 550 euro aber die aufhebung
der parität bei den minijobs das
kritisieren wir an der stelle sehr
darüber hinaus
kommt auch für die inklusions firmen und
gerade da wo menschen mit behinderung
beschäftigt werden noch eine ganz
entscheidende frage dazu wie es mit dem
nachteilsausgleich steht das ist eine
frage herr minister die bitte ich sie
dringend anzugehen und schleunigst
anzugehen damit die inklusions
unternehmen nicht im rahmen der
mindestlohn erhöhung letztlich leiden
das muss dringend dringend gelöst werden
und mit unserem entschließungsantrag
gehen wir genau auf diese kritikpunkte
ein und werden uns daher bei dem gesetz
enthalten darüber hinaus empfehlen wir
unseren entschließungsantrag
entsprechend zuzustimmen den letzten
sekunde in meiner rede will ich aber
doch noch mal einige dinge zum haushalt
bezüglich teilhabe politischer maßnahmen
sagen wir haben in der letzten
legislaturperiode in der großen
koalition einiges und wirklich muss
sagen viel gutes auf den weg gebracht
der koalitionsvertrag hat hier auch
viele projekte angesprochen aber bleibt
an vielen stellen aber immer noch unklar
und ungenau und beim haushalt ist es
genauso ein roter faden der ist hier
nicht zu erkennen vor allen dingen ist
zu kritisieren dass der ansatz bei den
forschungsmitteln zur untersuchung der
umsetzung des bundes teilhabe gesetzes
erheblich gesunken ist und darüber
hinaus sollte man auch schauen dass man
bei der arbeits und arbeitsmarkt
integration
doch auch aus als mittel zur verfügung
stellt hier besteht eine große
leerstelle und da wo sie noch die kurve
gekriegt haben ist bei den mitteln für
die bundesstelle barrierefreiheit und
über und die überwachung stellen für die
barrierefreie it die jetzt doch nicht
gekürzt werden die herausforderungen an
dieser stelle sind groß und ich würde
sie sehr bitten dass sie möglichst
schnell auch die aufgabe aus der letzten
legislaturperiode umsetzen dh die
ansprechstellen einzurichten damit
menschen mit behinderungen auf den
ersten arbeitsmarkt vermittelt werden
können ansonsten sehen wir ihren
vorhaben mit spannung und erwartungsfroh
entgegen dankeschön wilfried eggers war
das für die csu-fraktion ja teilweise
müssen sich die redner hier ein bisschen
aufteilen das wird ja über den
einzelplan beraten und parallel über den
gesetzentwurf zum mindestlohn
jetzt wollen wir mal dass peter ritzel
von der spd dazu noch zu sagen
wir setzen heute das um was wir
versprochen haben wir erhöhen den
gesetzlichen mindestlohn auf 12 euro die
stunde und das ist gut
wir wissen alle dass zwölf euro in der
stunde keine großen sprünge erlauben
aber es ist eine erleichterung für viele
die sehr sehr wenig geld haben gerade
wenn jetzt die preise steigen und es
macht einen unterschied für sechs
millionen bürgerinnen bürger das genau
das hat vor zwei tagen hier an diesem
pult unser bundeskanzler olaf scholz
gesagt und ich bin froh dass wir einen
bundeskanzler haben der uns nicht nur
sicher und souverän und bedacht und
zuverlässig durch die krise führt
sondern dass wir auch einen
bundeskanzler haben in dem auch noch ein
halber arbeitsminister steckt und
deswegen bin ich froh dass wir soziale
politik immer im blick haben und mehr
als ein halber nämlich mehr als ein
ganzer arbeitsminister ist hubertus heil
und deswegen bin ich froh dass wir das
auf den weg bringen
wir werden mit unserer politik sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen immer die
menschen im blick haben denen es nicht
so gut geht und deswegen ist auch ein
guter ausgestatteter sozialhaushalt so
wichtig weil er den menschen dient weil
dieses geld aber auch sofort wieder in
die wirtschaft fließt und die wirtschaft
stärkt und weil vor allem die demokratie
gefestigt wird damit sein dreiklang von
allem deswegen ist gutes sozialpolitik
immer es alle wichtigste fundament und
dafür geben wir auch über 160 milliarden
das ist über oder fast ein drittel des
bundeshaushaltes für sozialpolitik aus
wir beschließen neben dem höheren
mindestlohn heute auch eine höhere
minijob grenze aber verbessern vor allem
die möglichkeit der
sozialversicherungspflichtigen
beschäftigung nämlich im
übergangsbereich bei den sogenannten
midijobs wir sichern und stecken viel
geld in die
künstlersozialversicherung das ist ganz
wichtig und wir werden heute auch noch
mal an dieser stelle für die renten
etliches tun das ist alles ausgeführt
worden aber zusammenfassend ein
mindestlohn ist immer nur eine unterste
grenze es ist eine untergrenze wo ist
der runde 1 trotz sittenwidrig ist
menschen zu beschäftigen und ein
mindestlohn ist kein gold standard
goldstandards in tarifverträge und wir
werden alles tun tarifverträge zu
stärken eine renaissance so
tarifverträge zu haben und die letzten
20 sekunden von meiner gekürzten
redezeit ich verwende ich damit dass
sich heute für einen bäcker getroffen
habe aus berlin ein großbäcker und er
hat mir heute früh gesagt beim
mindestlohn ist er mittlerweile schon
drüber und er will tarifverträge nach
dem schließen wir uns doch an und dafür
lohnt sich gute soziale politik zu
machen bildern
bernd rützel
mit seinen persönlichen eindrücken oder
noch auch umberto zeil hatte ja schon
erzählt von einem friseurbesuch gestern
und den reaktionen der arbeitgeberinnen
auf die erhöhung des mindestlohns
stephan stracke jetzt für die minderung
des co präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren deutschland steht vor
gewaltigen herausforderungen
krieg energieknappheit und inflation
prägen unseren alltag viele kommen kaum
noch über die runden angesichts massiver
preissteigerungen an der zapfsäule bei
den heizkosten stromkosten bei den
lebensmitteln und angesichts dieser
situation hat in der ersten beratung zu
diesem haushalt am 25 märz die
bundesminister heil wörtlich gesagt sie
trat deshalb haben wir in den letzten
wochen entlastungs pakete auf den weg
gebracht um härten abzufedern nicht mit
der gießkanne zitat ende was sie damals
mit der gießkanne gemeint haben wird
jetzt jeder rentnerin und jedem rentner
klar von der energiepreis pauschale von
100 euro
euro haben sie nichts arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer selbstständige beamte
all diese bekommen die energiepreis
pauschale von 300 euro nicht jedoch die
rentnerinnen und rentner und verena
bentele die
vdk-präsidentin sagt dazu es kann nicht
sein dass die bundesregierung diese
generation mit ihren hohen heizkosten
einfach sitzen lässt recht hat sie die
vdk-präsidentin
die koalition stärkt mit ihrem
entlastungs paketen nicht in sozialen
zusammenhalt an dieser stelle sie
schwächt ihn in zentralen punkten und
hat jetzt diese koalition zum abschluss
dieser haushaltsberatungen dazugelernt
am 28 mai haben sie herr heil ein
interview gegeben in der westdeutschen
allgemeinen zeitung darf daraus zitieren
sie tat sie haben die hohen preise sind
für viele menschen wirklich kritisch und
dann bis sie weiter unten wir haben den
rentnern wir haben den rentner der sich
vor der nächsten heizkostenabrechnung
fürchtet das kann uns nicht egal sein
zitat ende
wirklich wenn es ihnen nicht egal ist
dann hätten sie dafür gesorgt dass die
300 euro für die rentnerinnen und
rentner jetzt auch tatsächlich im
haushalt stehen dass sie sie willkommen
wenn es ihnen nicht egal wer dann hätten
sie einen änderungsantrag als koalition
auf den weg gebracht das ist aber
erkennbar nicht der fall er heil werden
sie ihrer sozialen verantwortung gerecht
sie lassen die rentnerinnen und rentner
in dieser schwierigen situation im stich
das ist das gegenteil von sozialer
verantwortung
und statt zu handeln
kommen sie jetzt mit einem weiteren
vorschlag um die ecke das klima geht
nichts als ein etikettenschwindel denn
das klima geld ist keine
inflationsbremse sondern es ist ein
klima instrument es ist falsch die co2
bepreisung jetzt für weitere
leistungsversprechen zu verwenden ihr
vorschlag der heil ist ungerecht
unseriös und unverantwortlich
ungerecht weil er kinder nicht
berücksichtigt er ist familienfeindlich
er ist unseriös weil die
leistungsversprechen ins schaufenster
stellen ohne preisschild und es ist
unverantwortlich weil sie dies damit
keinen zusätzlichen
klimaeffekt haben sondern nur ein neues
ausgabenprogramm produzieren der
bürokratie aufwand ist gewaltig und
deswegen verwundert ist ja auch nicht
dass diese neue leistungsversprechen
alle heil nicht jetzt kommt sondern
frühestens zum ersten januar des
nächsten jahres aber die menschen
brauchen jetzt die entlastung sie
brauchen sie jetzt und nicht erst im
nächsten jahr
und so verwundert auch die reaktion von
lindner nicht im handelsblatt am 2 juni
in die immer sagt dieses klima geld ist
nicht vom koalitionsvertrag gedeckt und
zudem nicht so richtig verdacht nicht so
richtig durchdacht
die heiße entlastung wird also damit er
zu einer belastung für die koalition und
ich habe den eindruck dass die koalition
noch kein so wirklich gemeinsames
verständnis darüber entwickelt hat was
jetzt tatsächlich notwendig und richtig
ist und hier helfen wir ihnen an dieser
stelle sehr gerne als opposition weiter
wir empfehlen ihnen senken sie die
stromsteuer auf der auf das europäische
minimum hinab das ist ein instrument das
hilft das entlastet alle menschen mit
geringen einkommen sogar
überproportional denn sie bezahlen von
ihren gesamtausgaben einen höheren
anteil für strom und familien werden im
besonderen maße entlastet da mehr
personen auch mehr strom verbraucht und
es ist unbürokratisch weil sie einfach
nur ist gesetz verändern müssen die
änderung des steuersatzes und es ist im
übrigen auch ein beitrag zum klimaschutz
da strom basierte alternativen wie autos
oder wärmepumpen gegenüber fossilen
technologien gestärkt das ist der
richtige ansatz wenn es darum geht co2
preis um wenn es darum geht ein klima
geld auf den weg zu bringen das wirkt
machen sie einfach das was wir ihnen
vorschlagen und ich habe den eindruck
dass diese koalition auf einen heißen
herbst
zusteuert ein heißer herbst zum einen
weil ihre entlastungspaket auslaufen zum
anderen immer neue ausgabenprogramme auf
dem tisch gelegt werden und gleichzeitig
die schuldenbremse eingehalten werden
soll das kollidiert in gewaltiger art
und weise miteinander wir sind gespannt
und wir haben die besten vorschläge
dafür wie sie jetzt in dieser situation
agieren
[Applaus]
für die spd fraktion hat nun die
kollegin dr tanja machalet das wort wie
ist die letzte rednerin zu diesem
einzelplan bevor dann über einzelplan
und auch das ministerium gesetzt
abgestimmt wird
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen lieber streife die punkte die
sie zum schluss angeführt haben da würde
ich empfehlen die sich mit diesen
vorschlägen an bundesfinanzminister
lindner zu wenden das sind nämlich alles
vorschläge die eigentlich nicht direkt
mit dem einzelplan 11
zusammenhängen
richten sie ihre vorschläge an sie ich
komme gleich noch dazu aber ich möchte
zunächst einmal festhalten
unser bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat am
mittwoch in der generaldebatte gesagt in
diesen zeiten wo große veränderungen
stattfinden da ist es umso wichtiger
dass sich alle verlassen können auf
sicherheit und zusammenhalt und das
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
möchte ich hier zum abschluss der
debatte schon auch mal festhalten bildet
der einzelplan elf mit seinem
gesamtausgaben volumen von 116 61
milliarden euro ab
und ich habe mich die ganze zeit im
verlauf der debatte gefragt bei den
beiträgen von aus der cdu was wollen sie
eigentlich ja sie schimpfen hier über
die hohen ausgaben
sagen aber nicht wirklich was sie was
sie wollen das einzige woran sie sich
abarbeiten ist an sanktionsmoratorium
und am mindestlohn das sind ihre
einzigen punkte mit denen sie hier
aufwarten und den übrigen spielen sie
sich dann doch als die partei der
rentnerinnen und rentner auf ich möchte
nur noch mal daran erinnern erklären sie
doch bitte erst mal ihre haltung zum
rentenniveau klären sie ihre haltung zum
renteneintrittsalter und tankwart das
über das passiert
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in den
letzten in der letzten zeit wird ja viel
über die spaltung der gesellschaft
gesprochen und von vielen gerade von der
seite wird sie auch herbeigeredet dieser
haushaltsplan und auch das möchte ich
noch mal deutlich sagen spricht eine
andere sprache nämlich die wie wir den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt weiter
stärken werden und oft sind es im
übrigen nicht die großen positionen
sondern das sind die vermeintlich
kleinen positionen die im haushalt
abgebildet sind die wirklich eine große
wirkung entfalten ich will hier auf die
bundesagentur für arbeit hinweisen die
wirklich einen wichtigen beitrag dafür
leistet für zusammenhalt und das hat sie
insbesondere in der korona pandemie beim
kurzarbeitergeld
bewiesen mit der auszahlung es war nach
meiner meinung das wichtigste instrument
um den bürgerinnen und bürgern aber auch
um den unternehmen sicherheit in der
pandemie zu geben und ich will an dieser
stelle wirklich noch einmal ausdrücklich
den mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in
der bundesagentur danken das war eine
herausragende leistung wir wissen dass
wirklich sehr zu schätzen
zum schluss möchte ich noch auf
die 107 milliarden euro rente zuschuss
für die rente eingehen wir haben ja
heute nachmittag noch eine kollegin
debatte ich komme zum schluss auch das
sind leistungen die wir
deutlich unterstützen denn wir
stabilisieren das rentenniveau das sind
gelder für den grundtrend zuschuss und
weitere renten rentenarten dazu stehe
ich dazu stehen dir und wir werden das
auch weiterhin tun ich freue mich auf
viele weitere debatten herzlichen dank
aber erstmal wird nicht weiter
debattiert sondern abgestimmt gehören
neben mal die bundestags-vizepräsidentin
petra pau schließe die aussprache und
bitte die kolleginnen und kollegen die
noch stehen sich auch zu setzen damit
ich hier abstimmungsergebnisse die wir
gleich feststellen wollen auch
zweifelsfrei
feststellen kann wir kommen zur
abstimmung über den einzelplan 11
bundesministerium für arbeit und
soziales in der ausschuss fassung hierzu
liegt ein änderungsantrag der fraktionen
der cdu/csu auf drucksache
2052 vor wer stimmt für diesen
änderungsantrag
zum bei diesem änderungsantrag der union
zum einzelplan geht es darum dass ein
bestimmter haushaltstitel herabgesetzt
werden soll das ist nämlich geld das
vorgesehen ist für das
gesetzgebungsverfahren den übergang zum
bürgergeld in der debatte kam das ja
auch durchaus ab und zu dann zur sprache
und hubertus heil vor allem hat gesagt
zum ersten januar soll das bürgergeld ja
eingeführt werden das soll ja
letztendlich die grundsicherung für
arbeitssuchende oder hartz 4 ersetzen
und dafür wie gesagt da die union das
bürgergeld ablehnt sagt hier auch dieser
vorbereitende haushaltstitel soll nicht
stattfinden
bestimmt dagegen
danke er enthält sich der einzelplan 11
ist mit den stimmen der spd fraktion der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen und der
fdp fraktion gegen die stimmen der cdu
csu fraktion der fdp fraktion und der
fraktion die linke
angenommen so nachdem der
änderungsantrag abgelehnt worden ist
jetzt zweiter beratungen über den
einzelplan der bundesregierung eines
natürlich angenommen mit mehrheit der
koalitionsfraktionen es durch den
gesetzlichen mindestlohn und zu
änderungen im bereich der geringfügigen
beschäftigung
der ausschuss für arbeit und soziales
empfiehlt unter buchstabe aus einer
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache
1916 den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung auf drucksache
1408 anzunehmen wir liegen hier zu
mehreren erklärungen nach § 31 unserer
geschäftsordnung form entsprechend
unseren regeln nehmen wir diese zum
protokoll
die fraktion die linke hat beantragt
über den gesetzentwurf getrennt
abzustimmen und zwar zum einen über den
artikel 7 änderung des vierten buches
sozialgesetzbuch hier
geringfügigkeitsgrenze
und zum anderen über den gesetzentwurf
im übrigen ich rufe zunächst auf artikel
sieben die fraktion die linke hat
namentliche abstimmung verlangt die
abstimmung erfolgt in der west lobby sie
haben zur abgabe ihrer stimme nach
eröffnung der abstimmung 20 minuten zeit
ich weiß schon jetzt darauf hin dass
nach der namentlichen abstimmung
während der auszählung des ergebnisses
die sitzung unterbrochen wird ich bitte
die schriftführerin und schrift hörer
die plätze einzunehmen das ist schon
geschehen
ich eröffne die namentliche abstimmung
über artikel 7 die abstimmungs omen
werden um 12 uhr 10 geschlossen so jetzt
noch mal kurz zur erklärung bevor dann
die erste abstimmung hier zumindest die
erste namentliche erfolg wie gesagt
einzel anderen wir jetzt schon sozusagen
abgearbeitet also das mindestlohngesetz
die linke hat hier beantragt weil ja in
diesen mindestlohn gesetzt wenn sie die
debatte verfolgt haben noch mehr drin
steckt nicht nur die erhöhung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohn auf 12 euro
sondern auch die geplante ausweitung der
geringfügigkeitsgrenze bei minijobs auf
520 euro dagegen spricht sich die linke
aus weil die linke sagt minijobs an sich
würden keine eigenständige
existenzgrundlage sein das heißt kein
anspruch auf
arbeitslosengeld würde man erwerben
damit und die linke ist gegen diese
erhöhungen und generell gegen die
minijobs und hat deswegen gesagt wir
können nicht über diesen gesetzentwurf
abstimmen in dem zwei verschiedene
punkte stecken und hat deswegen ein
amtlicher abstimmung über diesen einen
punkt
beantragt da wird jetzt in der westler
baby haben einige bilder für sie
vorbereitet abgestimmt namentlich weil
man das ja immer noch nicht hier im
plenarsaal macht sondern in die westlb-
sich vertagt aus corona gründen damit
mich alle sozusagen gleichzeitig ihre
karten hier ein schmeißen müssen
einwerfen müssen in die urnen das ganze
ist 20 minuten geöffnet sie haben es wir
sehen also es gibt rote karten und blaue
karten und weise karten wie gesagt also
das wäre natürlich hier für sie
verfolgen erst dann wird über den
mindestlohn abgestimmt das ganze
ungefähr in einer halben stunde dann
sind wir wieder hier live für sie zurück
ich darf noch auf hinweisen gegen 14 uhr
erst wird hier ungefähr über das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
debattiert